This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The past is not a place where my mind naturally wanders. My colleagues and friends can tell you that for better or worse, my focus is almost always on what lies ahead. But it's a very specific moment from the past that I've been thinking about a lot in recent days. It was March 2018 and a snowstorm was headed for New York City. I wasn't in New York, but that storm was the focus of all my worry and attention.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。过去并不是我大脑自然会游荡的地方。我的同事和朋友可以告诉你，无论好坏，我的注意力几乎总是集中在未来。但最近几天，我一直在思考过去的一个非常具体的时刻。那是2018年3月，一场暴风雪正向纽约市袭来。我当时不在纽约，但那场风暴是我所有担忧和关注的焦点。
That's because New York was the home of the great psychologist and Nobel Prize winner Daniel Kahneman. We had invited him to come to NPR studios in Washington DC to tape an episode with us in front of a live audience that had come in from around the country. Danny was worried that the storm might keep him from returning to New York and he really needed to get back after the event. It looked like the storm would derail our plans. Mother Nature was not gracious that day. But Danny was. He extended his stay in Washington, D.C., and the conversation I had with him is one of
那是因为纽约是伟大的心理学家、诺贝尔奖得主丹尼尔·卡尼曼的家。我们曾邀请他来到华盛顿特区的NPR演播室，在从全国各地赶来的现场观众面前录制一期节目。丹尼担心暴风雪可能会让他无法返回纽约，而活动结束后他确实需要赶回去。看起来这场风暴会打乱我们的计划。大自然那天并不仁慈。但丹尼很仁慈。他延长了在华盛顿特区的逗留时间，我和他的那次谈话是我
my favorite memories as host of the show. It's now also a memory that's tinged with sadness. Daniel Kahneman died on March 27th. He was 90 years old. It's hard to overstate the foundational role that Danny has played in our modern understanding of human behavior. So today, we thought we'd bring you a special episode looking back at two conversations I had with him. What they reveal is how far our understanding of the mind has come over the past century, and how much Danny and his intellectual partner,
作为节目主持人最美好的回忆之一。现在，这也是一段带有悲伤色彩的回忆。丹尼尔·卡尼曼于3月27日去世，享年90岁。很难夸大丹尼在我们对人类行为的现代理解中所发挥的奠基性作用。所以今天，我们想为您带来一期特别节目，回顾我与他进行的两次谈话。它们揭示了在过去的一个世纪里，我们对大脑的理解取得了多大的进步，以及丹尼和他的知识伙伴，
Amos Tversky, charted a path that has inspired the work of countless other researchers. Thinking. Fast, slow, and transformative. This week on Hidden Brain. If you've ever taken an Econ 101 class, you were probably taught what's long been a core idea in economics. People are rational. They seek out the best information. They measure costs and benefits and maximize pleasure and profit. This idea of the rational economic actor has been around for
阿莫斯·特沃斯基，是如何开辟了一条启发了无数其他研究人员工作的道路。思考。快与慢，以及变革。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。如果你上过经济学入门课，你可能被教导过经济学中长期存在的一个核心观点。人是理性的。他们寻求最好的信息。他们衡量成本和收益，并使快乐和利润最大化。这种理性经济人的观念已经存在了
centuries. But about 50 years ago, two obscure psychologists shattered these foundational assumptions. The psychologists showed that people routinely walk away from good money, and they explained why once people get in a hole, they often keep digging. The methods of these psychologists were as unusual as their insights. Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky spent hours together, talking. They came up with playful thought experiments. As Daniel Kahneman remembered it, they laughed a lot.
几个世纪。但大约50年前，两位默默无闻的心理学家粉碎了这些基本假设。这两位心理学家证明，人们经常会放弃唾手可得的钱财，并解释了为什么一旦人们陷入困境，他们往往会继续深陷其中。这两位心理学家的研究方法和他们的见解一样不同寻常。丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基在一起谈论了几个小时。他们想出了有趣的思维实验。正如丹尼尔·卡尼曼所回忆的那样，他们笑得很开心。
We found our own mistakes very funny. What was fun was finding yourself about to say something really stupid. Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky, who passed away in 1996, transformed the way we understand the mind. And that transformation had philosophical implications. The stories about the past are so good that they create an illusion that life is understandable. And that's an illusion.
我们发现自己的错误非常有趣。有趣的是发现自己正要说出一些非常愚蠢的话。丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基（于1996年去世）改变了我们理解大脑的方式。而这种转变具有哲学意义。关于过去的故事太好了，以至于它们制造了一种生活是可以理解的错觉。而那是一种错觉。
And they create the illusion that you can predict the future, and that's an illusion. And they create the illusion that you can predict the future. And that's an illusion. Life may not, as Danny says, be understandable, at least not fully. But that didn't stop me from asking him to reflect on his own journey. At our event in 2018, I started by asking him to look back on his life and how much of his success he would attribute to talent and how much to luck. I mean, you know, some talent was really needed, but luck, you know, I can see so many points
它们制造了一种你可以预测未来的错觉，而那是一种错觉。它们制造了一种你可以预测未来的错觉。而那是一种错觉。正如丹尼所说，生活可能并非完全可以理解，至少不完全是。但这并没有阻止我请他反思自己的人生旅程。在2018年的活动中，我首先请他回顾自己的一生，并询问他将多少成功归功于天赋，多少归功于运气。我的意思是，你知道，确实需要一些天赋，但运气，你知道，我能看到我生命中
in my life where luck made all the difference. And mainly the luck is with the people you meet and the friendships you make. There is a large element of luck in that. My life was transformed by sheer luck in finding a partner, an intellectual partner with whom we got along very well and we got a lot done. Before we get to Amos, I want to talk about another person whom you met. This was in 1941-42. You're a very young Jewish boy living in German occupied Paris. One day you're out beyond curfew, an SS officer spots you and runs up to you.
有太多的时刻，运气起到了决定性的作用。主要是与你遇到的人和建立的友谊有关的运气。这其中有很大的运气成分。我的生活因为找到了一个合作伙伴而彻底改变，一个与我相处得非常好、我们共同完成了很多工作的知识伙伴。在谈到阿莫斯之前，我想谈谈你遇到的另一个人。那是在1941-42年。你是一个住在德国占领区巴黎的犹太小男孩。有一天你过了宵禁时间还在外面，一名党卫军军官发现了你并向你跑来。
What happens next? Well, he doesn't run up to me, but he beckons me to him. And I was wearing a sweater. It was past the curfew and my sweater had a yellow star on it, and so I was wearing it inside out. And he called me and he picked me up and I was really quite worried that he might see my yellow star. He hugged me tight and then he put me down, he opened his wallet and he showed me a little
接下来发生了什么？嗯，他没有向我跑来，但他招手让我过去。我当时穿着一件毛衣。已经过了宵禁时间，我的毛衣上有一个黄星，所以我把它反穿了。他叫我过去，把我抱了起来，我当时真的很担心他会看到我的黄星。他紧紧地抱了我一下，然后把我放下，打开钱包，给我看了一个小
boy. Then he gave me some money and we went our separate ways. Obviously, I reminded him of his son and he wanted to hug his son so he hugged me. That's an experience that for some reason, I mentioned it in my Nobel autobiography but as illustrating a theme that was a theme in my family actually, my mother especially, that people are very complicated and that seemed to be an instance of something very complicated. And so it stayed that, in that sense, it's a memory that was important to me. So when an event like that happens, I can imagine most people just saying thank God
男孩的照片。然后他给了我一些钱，我们就分道扬镳了。显然，我让他想起了他的儿子，他想拥抱他的儿子，所以他拥抱了我。那是一种经历，出于某种原因，我在我的诺贝尔自传中提到了它，但它是为了说明我家庭中实际上存在的一个主题，尤其是我的母亲，即人是非常复杂的，那似乎是一个非常复杂事物的实例。所以它一直保持着那种状态，从这个意义上说，这是一段对我来说很重要的记忆。所以当这样的事情发生时，我可以想象大多数人只会说感谢上帝
and moving on, but you found it interesting, partly because you said there's something interesting that happened here. And from a very very young age it seems you were drawn to these curiosities about how the mind worked. In some ways the SS officer was making a mistake. He was looking at you and drawing an association from you to sort of to another child, maybe his own his own son and of course in many ways it was an error. It was it would the mind was not working in a quote unquote rational fashion, but it was more associative. Rupert Spira The complexity was that it's the combination of somebody who must have done some very evil things and have thought some very evil thoughts,
然后继续前行，但你觉得它很有趣，部分原因是你认为这里发生了一些有趣的事情。而且从很小的时候起，你似乎就被这些关于大脑如何运作的好奇心所吸引。在某种程度上，那名党卫军军官犯了一个错误。他看着你，把你和另一个孩子联系起来，也许是他自己的儿子，当然在很多方面这是一个错误。大脑并没有以所谓的“理性”方式运作，而是更具联想性。这种复杂性在于，一个人一定做过一些非常邪恶的事情，想过一些非常邪恶的想法，
and yet he was hugging me. And I mean, that kind of complexity was everywhere. I mean, Hitler, you know, liked children and liked flowers and was very kind to some people. So we have a lot of difficulty putting that together with the things he did. But that complexity was always interesting. At what point do you feel you became the person who was paying attention to his own thoughts? Because so many of your early insights were developed obviously in experiments that you ran on people, but you were also observing the way your own mind worked and observing,
然而他却拥抱了我。我的意思是，那种复杂性无处不在。我的意思是，希特勒，你知道，喜欢孩子，喜欢花，对某些人非常友善。所以我们很难将这一点与他所做的事情联系起来。但那种复杂性总是很有趣。你觉得你在什么时候成为了那个关注自己思想的人？因为你的许多早期见解显然是在你对他人进行的实验中发展出来的，但你也一直在观察自己大脑运作的方式，并观察，
if you will, oddities in the way that your own mind worked. Was that always the case with Danny Kahneman? I think so. I wrote a psychological essay when I was 11. It was short, but I'll tell you what the essay said actually because it shows quite a few things, I think. So my older sister was taking exams in philosophy, and I had read some Pascal, and Pascal explained why I gave proofs of God's existence. Pascal said that faith is God made sensible to the mind. A little boy of 11, very pompous of course, I said, how right.
如果你愿意的话，观察自己大脑运作方式中的怪癖。丹尼尔·卡尼曼一直都是这样吗？我想是的。我在11岁时写过一篇心理学文章。它很短，但我会告诉你那篇文章实际上说了什么，因为它展示了很多东西，我想。当时我姐姐正在参加哲学考试，我读过一些帕斯卡的作品，帕斯卡解释了为什么他要证明上帝的存在。帕斯卡说，信仰是上帝让心灵能够感知的。一个11岁的小男孩，当然非常自负，我说，说得太对了。
And then the psychological part was I said, but this is very hard. The experience of faith is very rare. And so that's why we have churches and organs and pump to sort of, and I called it ersatz, I mean, a sort of fake experience, to generate a fake experience. So that was, you know, that was psychology. And obviously, you know, that's what interested me then and it's interested me since. Later on as you were working as a professional psychologist now, you made in some ways a career of thinking about how your own mind worked. And I'm fascinated by this idea because in some ways, a lot of people look at how their minds work and they're defensive about it.
然后心理学部分是，我说，但这非常困难。信仰的体验是非常罕见的。所以这就是为什么我们有教堂、管风琴和排场，来，我称之为“替代品”，我的意思是，一种虚假的体验，来产生一种虚假的体验。所以，你知道，那就是心理学。显然，你知道，那就是当时让我感兴趣的东西，从那以后它一直让我感兴趣。后来，当你作为一名专业心理学家工作时，你在某种程度上以思考自己大脑如何运作作为职业。我对这个想法很着迷，因为在某种程度上，很多人观察他们大脑运作的方式时，他们会对此进行防御。
Or they defend how their minds work. Or they say, no, what I did made perfect sense. And instead in some ways, I think your humility, and clearly it's a temperamental quality of yours, helped you to sort of see some of these oddities and think about why they happen. That's not quite the way it happened, actually. I had my friend and collaborator, Amos and I, we worked together on that and nobody ever accused him of being humble. He was not.
或者他们为自己大脑运作的方式辩护。或者他们说，不，我所做的一切完全合乎逻辑。相反，在某种程度上，我认为你的谦逊——显然这是你的一种气质——帮助你看到了其中一些怪癖并思考它们为什么会发生。事实并非如此。我和我的朋友兼合作者阿莫斯一起工作，没有人指责他谦虚。他并不谦虚。
But what the two of us did, we found our own mistakes very funny. And so we had a lot of fun just exploring what is our first impulse when it's wrong. That can be an endless source of fun. There was no particular humility. On the contrary, in a way. That is, we never thought that people are stupid because we were finding all of that in ourselves and we didn't think we were stupid. There was very little humility there.
但我们两人所做的是，我们发现自己的错误非常有趣。所以我们只是在探索当我们犯错时我们的第一冲动是什么，这本身就很有趣。这可以是无穷无尽的乐趣来源。并没有什么特别的谦逊。恰恰相反，在某种程度上。也就是说，我们从不认为人们很愚蠢，因为我们在自己身上发现了所有这些，而我们并不认为自己很愚蠢。那里几乎没有什么谦逊。
What there was was irony, and the irony was part of the fun. What was funny about it? I can see why it was interesting or why it was curious, but I understand that when you and Amos worked together, there was just endless amounts of hilarity. There was a lot of laughter. And what was fun was finding yourself about to say something really stupid and sort of holding back because you know better. But it's that impulse to say things that are without basis or that are purely associative
那里有的是讽刺，而讽刺是乐趣的一部分。它有什么好笑的？我能明白为什么它很有趣或为什么它很奇特，但我明白当你和阿莫斯一起工作时，有无穷无尽的欢笑。有很多笑声。有趣的是发现自己正要说出一些非常愚蠢的话，然后因为你知道得更好而克制住。但那种说出没有根据或纯粹是联想性的东西的冲动
or that. And really it doesn't matter how intelligent you are or how educated you are. There are those intuitions or those thoughts that come from somewhere that come very reliably and predictably and that are wrong. Meeting Amos was clearly a stroke of luck. I don't think your life would have taken the same path that it did. Certainly not. I mean, it's rare, really, but he was exceptionally smart and very, very quick.
或者那样的东西。而且无论你有多聪明或受过多少教育，这都无关紧要。那些直觉或那些来自某处的想法，它们非常可靠且可预测地出现，而且它们是错误的。遇见阿莫斯显然是运气使然。我不认为你的生活会走上同样的道路。当然不会。我的意思是，这真的很罕见，但他异常聪明，而且非常、非常敏捷。
And there is, when you have two people who are working together, who really, in a way, love each other's mind and admire each other's mind. That is very special because it gives you a sort of confidence when you say something and the other person sees something in it that you haven't seen. And this is very rare, that this kind of mutual trust and looking for what's interesting and good in what the other person is saying. And both he and I, we were both quite critical people. I mean, he even more than I, but we made exception, an exception for each other. And that was a joy.
当你有两个在一起工作的人，他们确实在某种程度上热爱彼此的思想并钦佩彼此的思想时，这是非常特别的，因为它给了你一种自信，当你说了什么，而对方在其中看到了你没有看到的东西。这非常罕见，这种相互信任以及寻找对方所说内容中有趣和好的东西。我们俩都是相当爱批判的人。我的意思是，他甚至比我更爱批判，但我们为彼此破了例。那是一种快乐。
Psychologist Daniel Kahneman laid the groundwork for what is today known as behavioral economics. In 2002, Daniel Kahneman was awarded the Nobel Prize in Economics. So many of your early insights were based on thought experiments, where you came up with sort of very simple questions that you posed to both yourselves and to other people. Why these thought experiments?
心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼为今天所知的行为经济学奠定了基础。2002年，丹尼尔·卡尼曼被授予诺贝尔经济学奖。你的许多早期见解都是基于思维实验，你提出了对你们自己和他人提出的非常简单的问题。为什么选择这些思维实验？
And when we talked a few days ago, you actually said that this is part of the reason you think that your work appealed to a larger audience, because even if the ideas were complex, the questions were inherently interesting and accessible. Well that's a stroker block really. There's a famous psychologist, Walter Michel, who wrote a book on the marshmallows test a few years ago. His dissertation was with small children, and he asked those children two questions. One of them was, what do you want to be?
当我们几天前交谈时，你实际上说这就是你认为你的工作吸引了更广泛受众的部分原因，因为即使想法很复杂，问题本身也很有趣且易于理解。嗯，那确实是运气。有一位著名的心理学家沃尔特·米歇尔，几年前写了一本关于棉花糖实验的书。他的论文是关于幼儿的，他问了那些孩子两个问题。其中一个是，你想成为什么样的人？
The other question was, you can have this lollipop today or two lollipops tomorrow, what do you prefer? These two questions were correlated with everything in sight. I just fell in love with that idea of the psychology of single questions. I looked for ways to do that sort of thing. The work with Amos on judgment turned out to lend itself to just that. There is a single question that elicits a funny thought and it makes a point. And you know, in the first place, we were very lucky in the choice of problem.
另一个问题是，你今天可以得到这根棒棒糖，或者明天得到两根棒棒糖，你更喜欢哪一个？这两个问题与所见的一切相关联。我只是爱上了那种单一问题心理学的想法。我寻找做那种事情的方法。与阿莫斯在判断力方面的合作证明了这一点。有一个单一的问题可以引出一个有趣的思考，并说明一个观点。而且你知道，首先，我们在选择问题上非常幸运。
There are just no other problems in psychology that lend themselves to that sort of thing, that you can involve the reader and present questions to the reader and you make the reader think. You can do that in vision and there are those demonstrations of perceptual effects like figure ground or perceptual organization. They are on the page and that's the phenomenon. You are your own subject. Now you can do that on vision, you can do that on judgment, which is the field that
心理学中确实没有其他问题能适合那种事情，你可以让读者参与进来，向读者提出问题，并让读者思考。你可以在视觉上做到这一点，并且有那些感知效果的演示，比如图形背景或感知组织。它们就在页面上，这就是现象。你就是你自己的实验对象。现在你可以在视觉上做到这一点，你可以在判断力上做到这一点，这是我们进行研究的领域，
we did it in, and that's it. You can't do it on self-control, you can't do it on many other things. You can't do do in personality studies. When I was talking of luck, that's luck, to hit on something that we happen to be prepared for and that is uniquely, lends itself uniquely to something that creates experiences in readers. Sheer luck. So after many, many years of collaboration together, your partnership with Amos founded, I think it's fair to say. I'm wondering whether you've given the same thought to why that happened that you gave to other things that your mind does.
就是这样。你不能在自我控制上做到这一点，你不能在许多其他事情上做到这一点。你不能在人格研究中做到这一点。当我谈到运气时，那就是运气，碰巧遇到了我们准备好处理的事情，而且它独特地、独特地适合于在读者中创造体验的东西。纯粹的运气。所以经过多年多年的合作，我想说你们与阿莫斯的伙伴关系已经奠定了基础。我想知道你是否像思考大脑所做的其他事情一样，思考过为什么会发生这种情况。
And whether those insights, I mean so many of your insights about how your mind has worked have helped the rest of us. Is there anything here that could help the rest of us think about collaboration and partnership? No, I mean, you know, there's natural stresses in collaboration. The world is not kind to collaborations. You know, when you have two people who are reasonably talented and they work together and they overlap closely. Then I'm quoting Amos, he said, when I give a lecture, people don't think I need anybody else to do the work.
以及这些见解——我的意思是，你关于大脑如何运作的许多见解都帮助了我们其他人。这里有什么可以帮助我们其他人思考合作和伙伴关系的东西吗？不，我的意思是，你知道，合作中存在自然的压力。世界对合作并不友好。你知道，当你有两个相当有才华的人在一起工作，并且他们的工作密切重叠时。然后我引用阿莫斯的话，他说，当我做讲座时，人们不认为我需要其他人来完成这项工作。
And that was true to some extent of me as well. And so that creates stresses. Of course, I've given a lot of thought to it. We were fortunate that we went on as long as we did. We were fortunate that we remained friends, even when there were stresses in the collaboration and in the friction. I remember research that Abraham Tesser did many years ago where he looked at couples or other pairs of people who are very similar to one another. One of the things he found is, of course, the closer in similarity people were, the
在某种程度上，这对我也适用。所以这会产生压力。当然，我对此进行了很多思考。我们很幸运，我们合作了那么久。我们很幸运，即使在合作和摩擦中存在压力，我们仍然是朋友。我记得亚伯拉罕·泰瑟多年前所做的研究，他观察了非常相似的夫妻或其他成对的人。他发现的一件事是，当然，人们的相似度越接近，
more they reached for the same goal. You had, let's say, a couple who were both writers. The success of one person tended to make the other person feel smaller. Even though you're happy for your partner, there's a part of you that says, why can't I have the success that my partner has? It's a part of you that says, why can't I have the success that my partner has? And it's a very human thing. Yeah, of course. You know, and it's of course especially true if it's joint work, which that happens.
他们就越追求同一个目标。假设有一对夫妻都是作家。一个人的成功往往会让另一个人感到渺小。即使你为你的伴侣感到高兴，你内心的一部分也会说，为什么我不能拥有我伴侣那样的成功？你内心的一部分会说，为什么我不能拥有我伴侣那样的成功？这是一件非常人性化的事情。是的，当然。你知道，如果这是联合工作，那当然尤其如此，这种情况确实会发生。
So this is, you know, there's really a dynamic. And it's, I would say we were just about perfect for, you know, 10, 12 years, which is a very long time. When we come back, what Danny and Amos discovered together. Stay with us. Applause This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Today we are remembering psychologist Daniel Kahneman, who passed away recently at the age of 90. In the 1960s, Danny spent a summer with a group of eminent psychoanalysts at a treatment center in Massachusetts. The center
所以这是，你知道，确实存在一种动态。而且，我会说我们大约有10、12年是完美的，这是一个很长的时间。当我们回来时，丹尼和阿莫斯共同发现了什么。请留下来。掌声。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们正在缅怀最近去世的心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼，享年90岁。在20世纪60年代，丹尼在马萨诸塞州的一个治疗中心与一群杰出的精神分析学家度过了一个夏天。该中心
had a routine. A patient was examined for a month by multiple experts, then everyone came together to do a case study. They reviewed notes, they interviewed the patient together. One particular case left a strong impression on Danny. In the morning we learned that the woman, a young woman about whom we'd written the report had taken her life. And they did a very brave thing. They ran the case study. And I was deeply impressed both by the honesty of what they did, but what they were trying
有一个惯例。一名患者由多位专家检查一个月，然后大家聚在一起进行案例研究。他们审查笔记，一起采访患者。一个特定的案例给丹尼留下了深刻的印象。早上我们得知，我们为其撰写报告的那位年轻女性已经结束了自己的生命。他们做了一件非常勇敢的事情。他们进行了案例研究。我不仅对他们所做之事的诚实印象深刻，而且对他们试图
to do, they were seeing signs that they had missed. It was in retrospect, obviously, this was hindsight at work. Now you know what's happened, so you're seeing signs and premonitions. People are really feeling guilty. I saw her on the stairs and she looked strange. Why didn't I stop to inquire? People look strange all the time. So yeah that was that was an important episode. And of course what this episode reveals is how once an event happens we trace back a
做的事情印象深刻，他们看到了他们错过的迹象。回想起来，这显然是事后诸葛亮在起作用。现在你知道发生了什么，所以你看到了迹象和预感。人们真的感到内疚。我在楼梯上看到她，她看起来很奇怪。为什么我没有停下来询问？人们一直看起来很奇怪。所以是的，那是一个重要的插曲。当然，这个插曲揭示了当事件发生后，我们是如何追溯一个
story about how that event came to be and of course in journalism we do this all the time. I you know I remember after the 9-11 attacks we spent years sort of deconstructing all the errors that were made after the 9-11 attacks, we spent years sort of deconstructing all the errors that were made and drawing a pattern. When you see that pattern laid out, you have to say, well, those people must have been really dumb because it's so obvious that there was a pattern that led to the 9-11 attacks. Yeah. This is hindsight, and it's one of the most important phenomena actually in psychology, in the psychology of judgment, because you understand the past.
关于该事件如何发生的故事的，当然在新闻业中我们一直这样做。我，你知道，我记得在9-11袭击之后，我们花了几年时间来解构9-11袭击后犯下的所有错误，我们花了几年时间来解构犯下的所有错误并绘制出一种模式。当你看到那种模式呈现出来时，你不得不说，好吧，那些人一定真的很笨，因为导致9-11袭击的模式是如此明显。是的。这就是事后诸葛亮，实际上它是心理学中，在判断心理学中最重要的现象之一，因为你理解了过去。
The past surprises stop being surprising at the moment they happen. Then you have a story and you shouldn't have been surprised. When you reconstruct it, you also reconstruct wrongly what you believed at the time. So you minimize, you reduce a surprise. So not only was it inevitable, but also I almost, I really sensed it. So, you know, now where this goes really wrong and is that the stories about the past are so good
过去的惊喜在发生的瞬间就不再令人惊讶了。然后你就有了一个故事，你不应该感到惊讶。当你重构它时，你也错误地重构了你当时所相信的东西。所以你最小化了，你减少了一个惊喜。所以它不仅是不可避免的，而且我几乎，我真的感觉到了。所以，你知道，现在这真的出了问题的地方是，关于过去的故事太好了
that they create an illusion that life is understandable. And that's an illusion. And that they create the illusion that you can predict the future, and that's an illusion. And it's maintained by hindsight. So hindsight is a central phenomenon, really. And of course, the errors we make eventually led to Prospect Theory, which was the work
以至于它们制造了一种生活是可以理解的错觉。而那是一种错觉。它们制造了一种你可以预测未来的错觉，而那是一种错觉。它是由事后诸葛亮维持的。所以事后诸葛亮确实是一个核心现象。当然，我们犯的错误最终导致了前景理论，这是你因诺贝尔奖而受到引用的工作，
which you were cited for in the Nobel Prize among other things. If you were to explain Prospect Theory to an eighth grader, is there a way to do that? Well it's very easy to explain. It's much harder to make it interesting. And the theory that dominated thinking when we wrote, and to a very large extent still dominates economic thinking, was formulated first in 1738. So it's been around a long time. And what it says is that when you're looking at a gamble, what you're evaluating is you're evaluating two states of wealth.
除其他事项外。如果你要向八年级学生解释前景理论，有什么方法吗？嗯，解释起来很容易。让它变得有趣要难得多。在我们写作时主导思想的理论，并且在很大程度上仍然主导着经济思想的理论，最初是在1738年制定的。所以它已经存在很长时间了。它所说的是，当你观察一场赌博时，你正在评估的是你正在评估两种财富状态。
Your wealth if you will win and your wealth if you will lose and then if you're offered a sure thing instead of your wealth if you get that sure thing. And for 260 years and so, people accepted that theory. Instead of your wealth if you get that true thing and for 206 years and so people accepted that theory now the theory really is Doesn't make sense if you stop to think about it people don't think of gains and losses as states of wealth They just don't they think of gains and losses as gains and losses. That was the fundamental insight of prospect theory. You could ask if you get a Nobel Prize for that.
你赢了之后的财富和你输了之后的财富，然后如果你被提供了一个确定的东西，而不是你得到那个确定东西后的财富。260年来，人们接受了那个理论。而不是你得到那个确定东西后的财富，206年来，人们接受了那个理论，现在这个理论真的，如果你停下来思考一下，它说不通。人们并不把收益和损失看作是财富的状态。他们根本不这样看，他们把收益和损失看作是收益和损失。这就是前景理论的基本见解。你可以问，如果你因此获得诺贝尔奖。
You do in a certain context, because if it surprises people. One of the things you say in the book is, our comforting conviction that the world makes sense rests on a secure foundation, our almost unlimited ability to ignore our ignorance. And of course, you've spent a lifetime exploring the depths of your ignorance and all of our ignorance, but in many ways, there's something deeply human about this. To see the world as being chaotic and unpredictable and noisy is fundamentally unsettling, and it's easier to see the world
在某种背景下你会，因为它让人们感到惊讶。你在书中说的一件事是，我们对世界是有意义的这种令人欣慰的信念建立在一个稳固的基础上，即我们几乎无限的忽视我们无知的能力。当然，你花了一辈子时间探索你无知的深度和我们所有人的无知，但在很多方面，这其中有一些非常人性化的东西。将世界视为混乱、不可预测和嘈杂的是根本令人不安的，将世界视为
as understandable and comprehensible, and that fits in a story. Well, it's not, you know, we really have no option. I mean, the mind is created to make sense of things. I mean, vision makes sense of things. We see objects. We see objects moving. And it's the same with judgment and thinking. We have to make sense of things. And we can't do otherwise. So it's not, you know, that we would be unsettled
可理解和可理解的更容易，这符合一个故事。嗯，这不是，你知道，我们真的别无选择。我的意思是，大脑是为了理解事物而创造的。我的意思是，视觉理解事物。我们看到物体。我们看到物体在移动。判断和思考也是如此。我们必须理解事物。我们别无选择。所以这不是，你知道，如果我们不这样做，我们会感到不安
if we did otherwise. We can't. We make sense of things. We're sense-making organisms. And of course, it's worth pointing out that even though this leads to errors, it's also the case that much of the time this is enormously valuable and our sense-making ability actually works great, that it actually allows us to navigate the world successfully. Of course. I mean, you know, we're right almost all the time. I mean, you know, we couldn't survive if we weren't right almost all the time. We make interesting mistakes, and sometimes they're important mistakes,
我们不能。我们理解事物。我们是制造意义的有机体。当然，值得指出的是，即使这会导致错误，在很多情况下，这也是非常有价值的，我们的意义制造能力实际上运作得很好，它实际上使我们能够成功地驾驭世界。当然。我的意思是，你知道，我们几乎一直都是对的。我的意思是，你知道，如果我们不是几乎一直都是对的，我们就无法生存。我们犯了有趣的错误，有时它们是重要的错误，
but mostly we're very well adapted to our environment. So when you think about news events, if I tell you there are 19 hijackers who have flown planes into major buildings, and then we go back and we get biographical sketches of these people and we understand their ideologies and you know it activates things in our minds because of course there are these agents that are doing these things to us and you know we then spend hundreds of billions of dollars
但大多数时候我们非常适应我们的环境。所以当你想到新闻事件时，如果我告诉你，有19名劫机者驾驶飞机撞向主要建筑物，然后我们回去，我们获得了这些人的传记草图，我们理解了他们的意识形态，你知道，它激活了我们大脑中的东西，因为当然有这些代理人在对我们做这些事情，你知道，我们然后花费数千亿美元
trying to combat terrorism and you say okay that makes sense this is a major threat we've dealt with it but let's say you have another threat over here where I tell you that in 80 years or 100 years, the temperature might rise five degrees. And as a result of this, the oceans might warm a little bit, and sea levels might rise by two or three inches. And as a result of this, the models predict that climate events will become more serious, at least according to the models,
试图打击恐怖主义，你说好吧，这说得通，这是一个重大威胁，我们已经处理了它，但假设你有另一个威胁，我告诉你，在80年或100年后，温度可能会上升5度。结果，海洋可能会稍微变暖，海平面可能会上升两三英寸。结果，模型预测气候事件将变得更加严重，至少根据模型是这样，
but you have to understand probability. In order to try and head that off, you actually have to take very painful steps right now, maybe driving your car less, maybe living in a smaller house, all kinds of things that are painful in the here and now for something that seems difficult off in the distance and requires you to really understand statistics and probability. You've actually called climate change in some ways sort of a perfect storm of the ways in which our minds are not equipped to deal with certain kinds of threats. Yeah.
但你必须理解概率。为了试图阻止这一点，你实际上现在必须采取非常痛苦的步骤，也许少开车，也许住在一个更小的房子里，所有这些在此时此地都是痛苦的事情，为了一个看起来在远处且需要你真正理解统计学和概率的事情。你实际上在某种程度上称气候变化为我们大脑无法应对某些威胁方式的完美风暴。是的。
I mean, it's really, if you were to design a problem that the mind is not equipped to deal with, climate change would fit the bill. It's distance, it's abstract, it's contested. And it doesn't make, it doesn't take much. If it's contested, it's 50-50, for many people immediately. You don't ask, what do most scientists do? Which side of the National Academy of Sciences?
我的意思是，真的，如果你要设计一个大脑无法应对的问题，气候变化将符合要求。它是遥远的，它是抽象的，它是受争议的。而且它不需要太多。如果它是有争议的，对许多人来说，它立即就是50-50。你不会问，大多数科学家怎么做？美国国家科学院的哪一边？
That's not the way it works. Some people say this, other people say that. And if I don't want to believe in it, I don't have to believe in it. So it's... I'm really... Well, I'm pessimistic in general, but I'm pessimistic in particular about the ability of democracies to deal with a threat like that effectively. If there were a comet hurtling down toward us, you know, an event that would be predictable,
这不是它的运作方式。有些人这么说，另一些人那么说。如果我不想相信它，我就不必相信它。所以它是……我真的……嗯，我总体上是悲观的，但我特别悲观的是民主国家有效应对这种威胁的能力。如果有一颗彗星向我们冲来，你知道，一个可以预测的事件，
whether they, we'd mobilize. So it's not even that it's distant in time, but this is too abstract, possible, it's very different. We can't, we're not doing it in fact. So besides being pessimistic, does your research and understanding of this phenomenon give you any insight into how we should maybe talk about climate change and what we can do? I think scientists, in a way, are deluded in that they have the idea
无论他们，我们会动员起来。所以它甚至不是因为它在时间上很遥远，而是这太抽象了，可能的，它非常不同。我们不能，事实上我们没有这样做。所以除了悲观之外，你的研究和对这种现象的理解是否让你对我们应该如何谈论气候变化以及我们能做些什么有任何见解？我认为科学家在某种程度上是被误导的，因为他们有这样的想法
that there is one way of knowing things and it's you know things when you have evidence for them. But that's simply not the case. I mean, you know, people who have religious beliefs or strong political beliefs, they know things without having, you know, compelling evidence for them. things without having compelling evidence for them. There is a possibility of knowing things which is clearly determined socially. We have our religion and our politics and so on because we love or used to love and
即有一种了解事物的方法，那就是当你拥有证据时，你就了解事物。但事实并非如此。我的意思是，你知道，有宗教信仰或强烈政治信仰的人，他们在没有令人信服的证据的情况下了解事物。在没有令人信服的证据的情况下了解事物。有一种了解事物的可能性，这显然是由社会决定的。我们有我们的宗教和政治等等，因为我们爱或曾经爱过并
trust the people who held those beliefs. There is no other way to explain why people hold to one religion and think other religions are funny, which is really a very common observation. The only way would be to create social pressure. So for me, it would be a milestone if you manage to take influential evangelists, preachers, to adopt the idea of global warming and to preach it. That would change things.
信任那些持有这些信仰的人。没有其他方法可以解释为什么人们坚持一种宗教而认为其他宗教很有趣，这确实是一个非常普遍的观察。唯一的方法是制造社会压力。所以对我来说，如果你能让有影响力的传教士、牧师采用全球变暖的观点并宣扬它，那将是一个里程碑。那会改变事情。
It's not going to happen by presenting more evidence. That, I think, is clear. When we come back, we'll talk about happiness, memory, and noise. Stay with us. Thank you. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanathan. Daniel Kahneman won the Nobel Prize for a series of ideas that helped develop the field of behavioral economics. Danny, I don't know how you got an ethics panel to approve this study, but it's one of my favorite studies
通过提供更多证据是不会发生的。我认为这一点很清楚。当我们回来时，我们将谈论幸福、记忆和噪音。请留下来。谢谢。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。丹尼尔·卡尼曼因一系列有助于发展行为经济学领域的想法而获得了诺贝尔奖。丹尼，我不知道你是怎么让伦理委员会批准这项研究的，但这是我最喜欢的
of all time. Tell me about the colonoscopy study and the Pecan rule. Well, the colonoscopy study was devised to test an idea The colonoscopy study was devised to test an idea that when people form a memory of an episode or an impression of an episode that had a certain duration, that actually they completely neglect the duration. And what they're sensitive to are illustrative or crucial moments, and in particular when it's a painful experience. It's the peak of the pain and it's the end of the pain. It's how much pain you're at in the end.
研究之一。告诉我关于结肠镜检查研究和“峰终定律”。嗯，结肠镜检查研究旨在测试一个想法，即当人们形成对一段经历的记忆或对一段具有一定持续时间的经历的印象时，实际上他们完全忽略了持续时间。他们敏感的是说明性的或关键的时刻，特别是当它是一种痛苦的经历时。它是痛苦的顶峰和痛苦的结束。它是你最后痛苦的程度。
So that was a theory for which we had other evidence. And my friend Donald Vredeumer, who is a physician in Toronto, he volunteered to create a study around that. So study was run on people with a colonoscopy, which at the time was very painful. I mean, for those of you who have not reached the age of colonoscopy, it won't be painful when you have it, but at that time, it really was. People had a colonoscopy, and then half of them, it ended when it ended. For half of them, they left the tube in for another minute or so. Now, this is not pleasant.
所以这是我们有其他证据支持的理论。我的朋友唐纳德·弗雷德默，他是多伦多的一名医生，他自愿围绕这一点进行了一项研究。所以研究是在接受结肠镜检查的人身上进行的，这在当时非常痛苦。我的意思是，对于那些还没有达到结肠镜检查年龄的人来说，当你做的时候它不会很痛苦，但在当时，它确实很痛苦。人们接受了结肠镜检查，然后一半的人，它结束时就结束了。对于另一半人，他们把管子多留了一分钟左右。现在，这并不愉快。
Nobody would volunteer to have the tube in for another minute, but it improves the memory very significantly because it's less painful than what went on before. It's not desirable. You wouldn't choose it, but it makes a difference between a really aversive memory, which you have when they pull the tube at a moment of high pain. The whole thing is very bad. But if you end on a gentle note, even if it's still painful, the memory improves. Memory wasn't designed to measure ongoing happiness or to measure total suffering.
没有人会自愿让管子多留一分钟，但它非常显著地改善了记忆，因为它比之前发生的事情痛苦程度要低。这不是令人向往的。你不会选择它，但它在真正令人厌恶的记忆（当他们在痛苦的高峰时刻拔出管子时你所拥有的）和，整个事情非常糟糕。但如果你以温和的方式结束，即使它仍然很痛苦，记忆也会改善。记忆的设计并不是为了衡量持续的幸福或衡量总的痛苦。
For survival, you really don't need to put a lot of weight on duration, on the duration of experiences. It's how bad they are and whether they end well. That is really the information that you need for an organism. And so there are very good evolutionary reasons for the peak and end rule and for the neglect of duration. It leads to, you know, in some cases to absurd results. So if you are a policymaker, I feel like this is a real ethical dilemma. So let's say, for example, I'm running a hospital. I think the
为了生存，你真的不需要在持续时间、经历的持续时间上投入太多权重。它是它们有多糟糕以及它们是否以好的方式结束。这确实是你作为一个有机体所需要的信息。所以峰终定律和对持续时间的忽视有非常好的进化原因。它导致了，你知道，在某些情况下导致了荒谬的结果。所以如果你是一名政策制定者，我觉得这是一个真正的伦理困境。所以，例如，我正在经营一家医院。我觉得
colonoscopy study or versions of it have later found that if you actually give people the painful experience followed by the less painful experience, they are more likely to come back for the next colonoscopy because their memory of the colonoscopy was less painful. So you could argue from a public policy standpoint where you want people to get tested, the right thing to do is to extend their pain in order that they will remember the pain as being less and come back more often. However, also from an ethical point of view, you could argue that subjecting people to more pain
结肠镜检查研究或其版本后来发现，如果你实际上给人们痛苦的经历，然后是痛苦程度较低的经历，他们更有可能回来进行下一次结肠镜检查，因为他们对结肠镜检查的记忆不那么痛苦。所以你可以从公共政策的角度争辩说，你希望人们接受检查，正确的方法是延长他们的痛苦，以便他们会记住痛苦程度较低并更频繁地回来。然而，从伦理的角度来看，你也可以争辩说，让人们承受比你需要让他们承受的更多的痛苦是不道德的。所以我们该怎么办？那个很容易。我的意思是，你知道，有更难的版本。但那个很容易，因为你永远不会那样表述它。你只会告诉那些正在进行手术的人，最后要非常温柔。
than you need to subject them to is unethical. So what should we do? That one is easy. I mean, you know, there are harder versions of it. But that one is easy because you would never frame it that way. You would just tell the people who are doing the procedure, be very gentle at the end.
最后要缓慢而温柔，这听起来是一件好事。这对政策有好处，它会吸引更多的人。它会留下更好的记忆，它会提高依从性等等。所以有时有办法不表现得像你那样尖锐。你没有想到但你可以应用到自己身上的更困难的伦理困境是什么？嗯，我认为如果涉及真正的痛苦，某人处于痛苦中，我会说你可以处于痛苦中并且几乎没有意识，或者你可以处于痛苦中，他们会消除
Be slow and gentle at the end, and that sounds like a good thing. And it's good for policy, and it will get more people. It will leave better memories, it will more compliance, and so on. So there are ways sometimes of not presenting quite as sharply as you did. What would be a more difficult ethical dilemma that I didn't think of that you could apply to yourself? Well, I think that if real suffering is involved, somebody in pain, I'd say you can be in pain and barely conscious, or you can be in pain and they will eliminate
最后的记忆。你应该给病人可能在尖叫但不会记得的痛苦多少权重？这是一个伦理困境。当然，这确实有各种其他含义。你做了一些研究，观察，你知道，如果你可以去度假但你不能在度假时拍照，你会如何看待这次度假？换句话说，你本质上拥有这两种大脑运作的模型，即有一个体验生活的大脑，有一个记住生活的大脑，而这两个大脑并不总是相互同意。
the memory at the end. How much weight should you give to pain that the patient might be screaming but will not remember? That's an ethical dilemma. Of course, this does have all kinds of other implications. You've done some work looking at, you know, if you could go on a vacation but you couldn't take photographs on the vacation, how would you think about the vacation? In other words, you essentially have these two models of how the mind works, that there's
嗯，我的意思是，它们在某种程度上有着不同的利益。所以我谈到了体验自我，它是时刻生活的那一个。而记忆自我则是记分的那一个。产生的分数是由规则生成的，例如峰终定律等等。所以有时你可以看到经历的持续时间非常不同，它们如何
a mind that experiences life and there's a mind that remembers life, and these two minds don't always agree with one another. Well, I mean, they have different interests in a way. So I spoke of the experiencing self, which is the one that lives moment to moment. And the remembering self is the one that keeps score. And the scores that are generated are generated by rules, such as the peak end rule and so on. And so sometimes you can see that experiences are very different duration and how do they
重要？或者你应该赋予你不会记得或某人不会记得的经历什么价值。所以我在那个背景下的问题是，我的意思是考虑你下一次度假的计划。现在想象一下，在度假结束时，他们会销毁你所有的照片，并给你一种健忘症药物，这样你就什么都不会记得了。现在你会改变你的度假计划吗？
matter? Or what is the value that you should attach to an experience that you will not remember or that somebody will not remember. So my question in that context was, I mean consider your plans for your next vacation. And now imagine that at the end of the vacation, they will destroy all your pictures and they'll give you an amnesic drug so that you won't remember a thing. Now would you change your vacation plans?
如果你知道的话？实际上，许多人会，因为我认为许多人去度假是为了创造供未来消费的记忆，这并不总是发生。就我而言，它从未发生过。我从不看照片，但这是一种困境。所以你进行了一项研究，我记得，几年前。我想它发表在《科学》杂志上，你评估了父母在度过一天时感到多么快乐。
If you knew that? Many people would, actually, because I think many people go on vacations to create memories for future consumption, which doesn't always happen. In my case, it never happens. I never look at pictures, But that's a dilemma. So you conducted a study, I remember, a few years ago. I think it was published in the journal Science, where you evaluated how happy parents felt as they went through their days.
如果你知道这一点呢？事实上，很多人都会这么做，因为我认为很多人去度假是为了创造未来可以回味的记忆，但这并不总是能实现。就我而言，这种情况从未发生过。我从不看照片，但这确实是个两难的问题。所以我记得几年前你做过一项研究，好像发表在《科学》杂志上，你评估了父母在日常生活中感受到的幸福感。
And there's two ways you can, of course, ask the question. You can ask parents, how happy are you with parenting? And many parents will say it's the best thing they ever did. But then you can also ask parents on a moment to moment basis as they're in parenting how they feel and the answer turns out somewhat differently. Well yeah I mean it's you know it turns out that parenting if you really take the experiencing view of it then you know it's like washing dishes, you know, maybe a little worse often. And then, you know, and then it has its moments and it's the peak moments that people remember.
当然，你可以通过两种方式提出这个问题。你可以问父母：“你对为人父母感到多幸福？”许多父母会说这是他们做过的最好的事情。但你也可以在父母育儿的过程中，随时询问他们的感受，结果答案却大不相同。嗯，是的，我的意思是，事实证明，如果你真的从体验的角度来看待育儿，那么你知道，这就像洗碗一样，甚至往往还要糟糕一点。然后，你知道，它也有它的高光时刻，而人们记住的正是这些巅峰时刻。
And when people remember the peak moments, it makes the whole thing worthwhile. So it changes the meaning of the whole experience. So that was a much contested finding, very unpopular finding, but a very strong finding. If you look at the experiences, people have more fun with their friends than with their spouses, quite a bit. And if you were trying to make, to increase the happiness of the experiencing self,
当人们记住这些巅峰时刻时，这让一切都变得值得了。所以它改变了整个体验的意义。这是一个备受争议的发现，非常不受欢迎，但却是一个非常有力的发现。如果你观察这些体验，人们和朋友在一起比和配偶在一起时要快乐得多，多得多。如果你试图去增加体验自我的幸福感，
you would do very different things than people do because what people typically do, they try to satisfy their remembering self. Maximizing the happiness of your experiencing self would make you more social, less ambitious. It would make you spend a lot more time with people that you love or like or enjoy because it's very largely social. So there are important implications of that distinction. Is there any insight that someone can draw from this work about whether they should become
你会做的事情与人们通常所做的非常不同，因为人们通常做的是试图满足他们的记忆自我。最大化体验自我的幸福感会让你变得更善于社交，而不那么雄心勃勃。这会让你花更多的时间与你爱、喜欢或享受的人在一起，因为这在很大程度上是社交性的。所以这种区分有着重要的意义。关于是否应该成为
a parent given this discrepancy between the remembering self and the experiencing self? And I should remind you before you answer that your daughter is in the audience here with us. I have never met, almost never met people who regretted having had their children. So if you measure things by the remembering self, and that's really the only way. The point is that the experiencing self doesn't make decisions. All the decisions are made by the remembering self. And the remembering self never regrets having had children.
一名父母，考虑到记忆自我和体验自我之间的这种差异，有人能从这项工作中得出什么见解吗？在你回答之前，我应该提醒你，你的女儿就在这里的观众席中。我从来没有见过，几乎从来没有见过后悔生孩子的人。所以，如果你用记忆自我来衡量事物，那确实是唯一的方法。重点是体验自我不会做决定。所有的决定都是由记忆自我做出的。而记忆自我从不后悔生过孩子。
So, you know, from that point of view, the answer is clear. Psychologist Daniel Kahneman laid the groundwork for what is today known as behavioral economics. Danny explained many of these insights in his 2011 book, Thinking, Fast and Slow. You're working on a new book with a couple of other people, but it's also a new area that you're looking at. A lot of the earlier work looked at the issue of biases and errors, and there's a new focus for a lot of the work that you're doing right now, and it has to do with the question of noise. What does that mean? Well, there are really two kinds of, two broad families of error.
所以，你知道，从那个角度来看，答案很明确。心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼为今天所谓的行为经济学奠定了基础。丹尼在他2011年的书《思考，快与慢》中解释了许多这些见解。你正在和其他几个人一起写一本新书，但这也是你正在研究的一个新领域。早期的很多工作着眼于偏见和错误的问题，而你现在所做的很多工作有一个新的重点，它与“噪音”的问题有关。那是什么意思？嗯，实际上有两种，两大类错误。
There is bias and there is noise. Noise simply means randomness. It's variability that shouldn't be there. If you imagine target shooting, then where the cluster of shots is, that could be far from the target, that's bias. But the variability of the cluster, that's noise. Many people, and certainly I in the past, are very interested in biases. And we think in terms of biases much more than we did like 60 years ago, where people
那就是偏见和噪音。噪音仅仅意味着随机性。它是本不应该存在的变异性。如果你想象射击靶子，那么弹孔聚集的地方可能远离靶心，那就是偏见。但弹孔聚集的变异性，那就是噪音。许多人，当然包括过去的我，对偏见非常感兴趣。我们思考偏见的方式比60年前要多得多，那时人们
would think of random error. And I now think that we have exaggerated biases and that most errors are really noise. They're randomness. And it's a very different approach to error than focusing on biases. I mean, I don't want to overstate that biases are very important and so on, but noise has been neglected and I think it deserves attention. Do you think it has implications that are different from the implications related to bias when it comes to public policy, for example?
会想到随机误差。我现在认为我们夸大了偏见，大多数错误实际上是噪音。它们是随机性。这与关注偏见的方法截然不同。我的意思是，我不想夸大其词，偏见非常重要等等，但噪音一直被忽视，我认为它值得关注。你认为在公共政策方面，它是否具有与偏见相关的不同含义？
Is it easier to reduce the effects of noise to address them than bias? Well, certainly. I mean, you can, in the first place, if you take judgment away and have a computer make the decision, the computer will be noise-free. Algorithms are noise-free in the sense that you present the same problem twice, you'll get the same answer. Whereas if you present the same problem to different judges or to the same judge at different times of day, you are going to get different answers.
减少噪音的影响是否比解决偏见更容易？嗯，当然。我的意思是，首先，如果你取消判断，让计算机做出决定，计算机将是无噪音的。算法是无噪音的，因为如果你两次提出同一个问题，你会得到相同的答案。而如果你把同一个问题交给不同的法官，或者在一天中的不同时间交给同一个法官，你将会得到不同的答案。
So you can eliminate noise by algorithm, and I think we should do that wherever we can. And where we can't do that, we should, I think the implication is that we should try to structure the judgment process so as to make it more reliable. I'll give you an example where this really matters. There is a thing in the United States that people call the asylum lottery because people who ask for asylum get a judge, they get the judge at random and in some cases they have an 80% chance of getting through, and in other cases, 15.
所以你可以通过算法消除噪音，我认为我们应该尽可能地这样做。而在我们无法做到这一点的地方，我认为其含义是我们应该尝试构建判断过程，使其更加可靠。我给你举一个这真的很重要的例子。在美国有一件事，人们称之为“庇护彩票”，因为申请庇护的人会分配到一名法官，他们是随机分配到法官的，在某些情况下，他们有80%的机会通过，而在其他情况下，只有15%。
That's noise. And you really don't want it, I think. Well, we're in the process right now at Hidden Brain of hiring someone. And in fact, we just conducted two interviews today, and we have a couple tomorrow. And as I was doing the interviews, I was thinking about some of the work that you've done.
那是噪音。我认为你真的不想要它。嗯，我们现在正在Hidden Brain招聘某人。事实上，我们今天刚刚进行了两次面试，明天还有几次。当我在进行面试时，我一直在思考你所做的一些工作。
In some ways, this was your earliest work going back many, many decades, looking at how you can reduce errors in the interview process. And I don't know whether you think of it as bias or you think about it as noise, but either way, it leads to flawed outcomes. And you came up with a technique that could address it. Yeah, I actually did come up with a technique a little more than 62 years ago, actually. I was an officer in the Israeli army. It was 1954.
在某些方面，这是你几十年前最早的工作，研究如何减少面试过程中的错误。我不知道你是把它看作偏见还是噪音，但无论哪种方式，它都会导致有缺陷的结果。而你提出了一种可以解决它的技术。是的，我确实在62年前多一点的时候提出了一种技术。当时我是以色列军队的一名军官。那是1954年。
The Israeli army was very young. It was 1956, actually. I set up an interview system which is a template for a lot of what is going on and is certainly a template for the way I think decisions should be made. I haven't thought of that for many years. The template is you have a problem, you need to evaluate people, break it up into dimensions. What sounds elementary and I'm not going to say anything very surprising. Make judgments of each dimension independently of all the others. That's independence is essential.
以色列军队当时非常年轻。实际上是1956年。我建立了一个面试系统，它是很多正在进行的事情的模板，当然也是我思考决策应该如何做出的模板。我已经很多年没想过那个了。这个模板是：你有一个问题，你需要评估人，把它分解成维度。这听起来很基础，我不会说任何非常令人惊讶的事情。独立于所有其他维度来判断每个维度。这种独立性是必不可少的。
Don't form a general impression until you have all the information. Delay intuition. Don't give it up necessarily. Delay it. And the results are just better when you do things that way. And I think that's probably is very general as a way of thinking about judgment and decision making. It's a way of reducing noise, of increasing reliability, and it's not very costly. And I'd like to promote it.
在获得所有信息之前，不要形成总体印象。推迟直觉。不一定要放弃它。推迟它。当你这样做时，结果会更好。我认为这可能是一种非常通用的思考判断和决策的方式。这是一种减少噪音、提高可靠性的方法，而且成本不高。我想推广它。
So of course the idea, if I understand correctly, is you score people on different criteria, give them a ranking so that you're evaluating it, but there's also an interesting piece of advice, which I understand they still offer in the Israeli army when they're doing these evaluations, a final piece of advice after you've done the calculations. What is that advice? Yeah, well, that's... So I set up that interviewing system. I was 22 years old. And the people, the interviewers who were 19 years old, they really didn't like that
所以当然，如果我理解正确的话，这个想法是你在不同的标准上给人们打分，给他们一个排名，以便你进行评估，但还有一个有趣的建议，据我所知，他们在以色列军队进行这些评估时仍然提供这个建议，在你完成计算后的最后一条建议。那是什么建议？嗯，那是……所以我建立了那个面试系统。我当时22岁。而那些19岁的面试官，他们真的不喜欢那个
suggestion. What they really wanted was to have a heart-to-heart conversation and then to form a general impression of how good a combat soldier that individual would be. But they said, you are turning us into robots. And they had a point. And then I told them, OK, I'll compromise. You do it my way, the interview. You run the whole interview, just and you generate those scores independently, fact-based and
建议。他们真正想要的是进行一次交心的谈话，然后对那个人会成为一名多么优秀的战斗士兵形成一个总体印象。但他们说，你把我们变成了机器人。他们说得有道理。然后我告诉他们，好吧，我妥协。你按我的方式做面试。你主持整个面试，只是……你独立地生成那些分数，基于事实，
so on. Don't think of anything until the end. In the end, close your eyes and give a score. How good a soldier will that person be? Now much to my surprise, that intuitive score is really very good. It's as good as the average of the six traits and it's different so it adds content. So having an intuition, if you delay it, it's quite good. The kicker of that story was that about 50 years later or so I got a Nobel Prize, so for a short time I was a celebrity in Israel. They took me to the army, to my old base, and they explained how they were doing the
等等。直到最后才去想任何事情。最后，闭上眼睛，给出一个分数。那个人会成为一名多好的士兵？现在令我惊讶的是，那个直觉分数确实非常好。它和六个特征的平均值一样好，而且它不同，所以它增加了内容。所以拥有直觉，如果你推迟它，它是相当不错的。那个故事的妙处在于，大约50年后，我获得了诺贝尔奖，所以有一段时间我在以色列是个名人。他们带我去了军队，去了我的老基地，他们解释了他们是如何进行
interview because they were still using that system, essentially, but very little change. Then the commander was telling me, and then she said, and then we tell them, close your eyes. So that thing had lasted for 50 years, that expression. So what I love about that, it's not so much intuition versus bias, but it's more maybe by just delaying intuition, the intuition gets better. And of course, if you don't do the detailed analysis, you still have an intuition that feels very powerful.
面试的，因为他们基本上还在使用那个系统，几乎没有什么变化。然后指挥官告诉我，然后她说，然后我们告诉他们，闭上眼睛。所以那件事持续了50年，那个表达。所以我喜欢的是，与其说是直觉与偏见的对抗，不如说也许仅仅通过推迟直觉，直觉就会变得更好。当然，如果你不做详细的分析，你仍然会有一种感觉非常强大的直觉。
And your ignorance is sort of papered over by this tendency of the mind. You know, intuition is compelling as such. I mean, you know, we have the intuition almost by definition. We trust it. And so delaying this and remaining very close to facts as you collect your separate dimensions is really very useful and it permits an intuition that is well informed because normally we form intuitions very quickly and then we spend the rest of the time confirming that this intuition was right. That by the way is a fact. It's been studied that way in interviews.
而你的无知被这种思维倾向所掩盖。你知道，直觉本身就是令人信服的。我的意思是，你知道，我们几乎根据定义就拥有直觉。我们信任它。所以推迟它，并在收集各个维度时非常贴近事实，这确实非常有用，它允许一种信息充分的直觉，因为通常我们很快形成直觉，然后我们花剩下的时间来确认这个直觉是正确的。顺便说一句，这是一个事实。在面试中，人们就是这样被研究的。
People form impressions in the first minute or two and they spend the rest of the time testing that they're right and and of course confirming that they're right. So this was clearly an example of how you came up with a mechanism in some ways to overcome how the mind works but on many many other fronts it seems like the biases, errors that you've discovered, even yourself, you say that you don't necessarily, you're not the master of those biases after studying them for more than half a century. Yeah, I mean, even myself. I mean, I'm considered one of the worst offenders on many of these mistakes. I'm overconfident when I really preach against that, and I make extreme predictions when
人们在最初的一两分钟内形成印象，然后花剩下的时间来测试他们是对的，当然也确认他们是对的。所以这显然是一个例子，说明你是如何想出一个机制在某些方面克服思维运作方式的，但在许多其他方面，似乎你发现的偏见和错误，甚至你自己，你说你并不一定，在研究了半个多世纪后，你并不是那些偏见的主人。是的，我的意思是，甚至我自己。我的意思是，在许多这些错误上，我被认为是罪魁祸首之一。当我真正反对过度自信时，我却过度自信，当我
I preach against that. Some people read thinking fast and slow in the hope that reading it will improve their minds. I wrote it and it didn't improve my mind. I wrote it and it didn't improve my mind. It's not... those things are, you know, they're deep and they're powerful and they're hard to change. Danny, yesterday was your 84th birthday. Happy birthday. You've studied a great number of different things over the years, and you tell me that one of the things that you're actually interested in studying is the subject of misery.
反对极端预测时，我却做出极端预测。有些人读《思考，快与慢》是希望阅读它能改善他们的思维。我写了它，它并没有改善我的思维。我写了它，它并没有改善我的思维。这不是……那些事情是，你知道，它们很深，很强大，而且很难改变。丹尼，昨天是你84岁生日。生日快乐。多年来你研究了许多不同的事物，你告诉我，你实际上感兴趣研究的事情之一是苦难的主题。
Much more than happiness, you're fascinated by misery. Now of course, I can just put this down to the pessimism that clearly you've demonstrated for a long time, but you actually say you can draw more specific conclusions, and there are takeaways from studying misery than from studying happiness. Yeah, I'm actually, you know, I contributed to what is called happiness research, but I'm really disturbed by it and I'm disturbed by positive psychology, in part because I think that making people happier is, you know, could be important, hard to do. It may not be society's business to make people happier, but reducing suffering, that's something
比起幸福，你更着迷于苦难。现在当然，我可以把这归结为你长期以来表现出的悲观情绪，但你实际上说，比起研究幸福，你可以从研究苦难中得出更具体的结论，并且有更多的收获。是的，我实际上，你知道，我为所谓的幸福研究做出了贡献，但我对此感到不安，我对积极心理学感到不安，部分原因是我认为让人们更快乐，你知道，可能很重要，但很难做到。让人们更快乐可能不是社会的职责，但减少痛苦，那是
else. It's easy to agree that this is important. It's easy to agree that society should be involved. Furthermore, it's easier to measure misery than to measure happiness, and what we can do about it is clearer than what we can do to enhance happiness. From all these points of view, I think that, and again, it's a matter of semantic luck. We speak of length and not of shortness, and so we speak of happiness and not of the other side of unhappiness.
另一回事。很容易同意这很重要。很容易同意社会应该参与其中。此外，衡量苦难比衡量幸福更容易，而且我们能对此做些什么比我们能做些什么来增强幸福更清晰。从所有这些观点来看，我认为，而且这又是一个语义运气的问题。我们说“长”而不是“短”，所以我们说“幸福”而不是“不幸福”的另一面。
But if you focus on unhappiness and misery you end up doing very different things, thinking very different thoughts and taking different actions which I think we should do. So you've been a wonderful sport Danny and really grateful for you for coming down and I am almost a little shame-faced about doing what I'm about to do right now, which is I'm wondering if we can increase your happiness just a tad, but it might increase your misery by singing Happy Birthday to You. You're one of Hidden Brain's heroes,
但如果你专注于不幸福和苦难，你最终会做非常不同的事情，思考非常不同的想法，并采取不同的行动，我认为我们应该这样做。所以你一直是一个很棒的伙伴，丹尼，真的很感谢你过来，我对自己即将要做的事情感到有点羞愧，那就是我想知道我们是否可以通过为你唱《生日快乐歌》来稍微增加一点你的幸福感，但这可能会增加你的苦难。你是Hidden Brain的英雄之一，
and we feel that it's really appropriate to end with that. So on the count of three, happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday dear Danny. Happy birthday to you. Thank you. Thank you.
我们觉得以这种方式结束真的很合适。所以数到三，祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，亲爱的丹尼。祝你生日快乐。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Danny Kahneman, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brains 100th episode. My pleasure. Several years after this conversation with Danny Kahneman, he published the book he mentioned on the topic of noise. In 2021, we brought him back to Hidden Brain for a second chat and a deeper dive into that idea. That's the conversation you're going to hear next.
谢谢。丹尼·卡尼曼，感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain的第100集节目。我的荣幸。在与丹尼·卡尼曼的这次谈话几年后，他出版了他提到的关于噪音主题的书。2021年，我们请他回到Hidden Brain进行第二次聊天，并更深入地探讨那个想法。这就是你接下来要听到的谈话。
I hope you enjoy it. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're going to start today with a little experiment. I'll be the guinea pig. I'm going to open the Stopwatch app on my phone. I'll hit start and count off 5 seconds while looking at the phone. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
希望你喜欢。这是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们今天从一个小实验开始。我来当小白鼠。我打开手机上的秒表应用程序。我会点击开始并看着手机数5秒。1，2，3，4，5。
Okay, let me do that again. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Okay, now I'm going to hit start and count off 5 seconds without looking at the phone. 1, 2, 3, four, five. It was 5.43 seconds. Last time. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. 5.59 seconds. The errors I made seem trivial, but it turns out they are not. Multiply the small mistakes I made in milliseconds over all the countless decisions I make every day, and you can end up with a serious problem. Multiply the errors I make as an individual by an entire society made up of other error-prone humans, and you
好的，让我再做一次。1，2，3，4，5。好的，现在我点击开始，不看手机数5秒。1，2，3，4，5。是5.43秒。上次。1，2，3，4，5。5.59秒。我犯的错误似乎微不足道，但事实证明并非如此。把你每天做出的无数决定中我以毫秒为单位犯下的小错误乘以起来，你最终可能会遇到一个严重的问题。把你作为一个个体犯下的错误乘以一个由其他容易犯错的人类组成的整个社会，你
can get disaster. What makes these mistakes insidious is that they are rarely the result of conscious decision-making. Human judgment is imprecise, and imprecise judgment produces unwanted variability, what the Nobel Prize-winning psychologist Daniel Kahneman calls noise. Wherever there is judgment, there is noise, and there is more of it than you think. This week on Hidden Brain, the gigantic effect of inadvertent mistakes in business, medicine, and the criminal justice system, and how we can save us from ourselves. Daniel Kahneman's insights into how we think have revolutionized many areas of the social sciences.
可能会导致灾难。这些错误之所以阴险，是因为它们很少是有意识决策的结果。人类的判断是不精确的，而不精确的判断会产生不必要的变异性，这就是诺贝尔奖得主心理学家丹尼尔·卡尼曼所说的“噪音”。只要有判断，就有噪音，而且噪音比你想象的要多。本周在Hidden Brain，探讨商业、医学和刑事司法系统中无意错误带来的巨大影响，以及我们如何从自己手中拯救自己。丹尼尔·卡尼曼关于我们如何思考的见解彻底改变了社会科学的许多领域。
He was my guest on Hidden Brain for our 100th episode. We talked about his early research and his first book, Thinking, Fast and Slow. As we close in on our 200th episode, we wanted to bring him back to talk about a set of ideas he's been working on for several years. They're described in his new book, Noise, a flaw in human judgment. Daniel Kahneman, welcome to Hidden Brain.
他是我Hidden Brain第100集节目的嘉宾。我们谈到了他早期的研究和他第一本书《思考，快与慢》。随着我们接近第200集，我们想请他回来谈谈他几年来一直在研究的一系列想法。它们在他的新书《噪音：人类判断的缺陷》中有所描述。丹尼尔·卡尼曼，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。
Glad to be here. I want to begin by exploring what you mean by the term noise. You spend some time studying an insurance company and one of the things an insurance company needs to do is to tell prospective clients how much their premiums are going to cost. So an underwriter says if you want us to cover you against this loss here's this quote. From the insurance company's point of view Danny, what is the risk of offering quotes that are too high and also quotes that are too low? Well, a quote that is too high, you are very likely to lose the business because there
很高兴来到这里。我想从探讨你所说的“噪音”这个词的含义开始。你花了一些时间研究一家保险公司，保险公司需要做的事情之一是告诉潜在客户他们的保费要花多少钱。所以承保人会说，如果你想让我们为你承担这个损失，这是报价。从保险公司的角度来看，丹尼，提供过高和过低的报价有什么风险？嗯，报价过高，你很有可能会失去这笔生意，因为
are competitors and they'll offer a better price. A quote that is too low, you're leaving money on the table and you may not be covering your losses if you do that a great deal. So errors in both directions are costly. We define noise as unwanted variability in judgments or decisions. That is, if the same client would get different quotes from different underwriters in the same company, this is bad for the company. And variability is a basic component of error.
有竞争对手，他们会提供更好的价格。报价过低，你就是在放弃利润，如果你这样做很多，你可能无法覆盖你的损失。所以两个方向的错误都是代价高昂的。我们将噪音定义为判断或决策中不必要的变异性。也就是说，如果同一个客户从同一家公司的不同承保人那里得到不同的报价，这对公司来说是坏事。而变异性是错误的基本组成部分。
So I think of the insurance business as being driven by mathematics. That's my stereotype, that there are hard-nosed statisticians who work at these companies. So I would not expect a quote from one underwriter to be wildly different from the next. You asked executives at this insurance company how much variability they expected between underwriters. What was their estimate of this kind of subjective variability? I mean, it turns out that there is a very general answer to that question. People have a very general idea about that number will be, and it's around 10%.
所以我认为保险业务是由数学驱动的。这是我的刻板印象，这些公司里有强硬的统计学家。所以我不会期望一个承保人的报价会与下一个有天壤之别。你问过这家保险公司的高管，他们预计承保人之间会有多少变异性。他们对这种主观变异性的估计是多少？我的意思是，事实证明，对于那个问题有一个非常普遍的答案。人们对那个数字会是多少有一个非常普遍的想法，大约是10%。
Now, when we actually measured that in an insurance company, the answer was 55%. And that was a number, that was an amount of variability, as we call it, an amount of noise that no one expected. And that really is what set me off on this journey that led to this book. Now, the difference between 10% and 55% might seem trivial. Who cares? Well, the consequences of this variability were anything but trivial.
现在，当我们真正在一家保险公司测量时，答案是55%。这是一个数字，是一个变异量，正如我们所说的，是一个没有人预料到的噪音量。这确实是我踏上导致这本书的旅程的原因。现在，10%和55%之间的差异看起来可能微不足道。谁在乎呢？嗯，这种变异性的后果绝非微不足道。
I mean, I asked people what actually would be the cost of setting up a premium that is too high or too low. And when they carried out that exercise, they thought that the overall cost of these mistakes was in the billions of dollars. Now what was in some sense saving that company was that probably other companies were noisy as well. But if you have a company that is noisy while others are noise-free, the noisy company is going to lose a lot of money very quickly.
我的意思是，我问人们设置过高或过低的保费实际上会付出什么代价。当他们执行那个练习时，他们认为这些错误的总成本是数十亿美元。现在，在某种意义上拯救那家公司的是，可能其他公司也存在噪音。但如果你有一家公司存在噪音，而其他公司没有噪音，那么有噪音的公司很快就会损失很多钱。
So with the insurance company, it's not just that the insurance company is losing money. There is also a cost that's being paid by all the people who are trying to get insurance. It might be that if you happen to get a quote that's too high, you might end up being uninsured or you might be spending more on insurance that you need to be spending. There is sort of a general human cost to these errors, not just in terms of the bottom line for the insurance company. Well, of course, when you have a noisy underwriting system, then the customer is facing a lottery that the customer has not signed up for.
所以对于保险公司来说，不仅仅是保险公司在亏钱。所有试图获得保险的人也在付出代价。可能如果你碰巧得到的报价过高，你最终可能没有保险，或者你可能在保险上花费了比你需要花费更多的钱。这些错误有一种普遍的人类成本，不仅仅是保险公司的底线。嗯，当然，当你有一个有噪音的承保系统时，客户面临的是一个客户没有签署的彩票。
And that is true everywhere. That is, wherever people reach a judgment or a decision by using their mind rather than computing, wherever there is judgment, there is noise, and there is more of it than you think. I want to look at a few other places, because in some ways what's striking about your book is both the number of different domains where you see noise and the extent of noise in those different domains including in places where you really feel this should be a setting where noise does not play a role.
这在任何地方都是如此。也就是说，无论人们是通过使用大脑而不是计算来做出判断或决定，只要有判断，就有噪音，而且噪音比你想象的要多。我想看看其他几个地方，因为在某些方面，你的书引人注目的是你在其中看到噪音的领域数量之多，以及在这些不同领域中噪音的程度，包括在你真正觉得这应该是一个噪音不发挥作用的环境中。
You cite a study done by Jaya Ramji Nogales and her co-authors who found that in asylum cases, this was a courtroom in Miami, one judge would grant asylum to 88% of the applicants and another granted asylum to only 5% of the applicants. So this is more than a lottery. This is like playing roulette. This is a scandal. Clearly the system isn't operating well. In many situations
你引用了Jaya Ramji Nogales和她的合著者所做的一项研究，他们发现，在庇护案件中，这是一个迈阿密的法庭，一位法官会批准88%的申请人庇护，而另一位法官只批准了5%的申请人庇护。所以这不仅仅是彩票。这就像玩轮盘赌。这是一个丑闻。显然系统运行得不好。在许多情况下
it's just that when people look at the same data they see them differently. They see them more differently than they expect. They see them more differently than anyone would expect. That's the basic phenomenon of what we call system noise. That is, when you have a system that ought to be producing judgments or decisions that are predictable, they turn out not to be predictable, and that's noise. You also describe in some ways there are different kinds of noise. So if you're an asylum judge and I'm an asylum judge and we have very different subjective readings that can produce very different answers.
只是当人们看同样的数据时，他们看待它们的方式不同。他们看待它们的方式比他们预期的要不同得多。他们看待它们的方式比任何人预期的都要不同得多。这就是我们所说的系统噪音的基本现象。也就是说，当你有一个本应产生可预测的判断或决策的系统时，它们结果却变得不可预测，这就是噪音。你还描述了在某些方面有不同种类的噪音。所以如果你是庇护法官，而我是庇护法官，我们有非常不同的主观解读，这可能会产生非常不同的答案。
But it could also be that if you are reviewing a case in the morning and you are reviewing a case in the afternoon, it's possible that just within yourself, your own judgments can be noisy. Can you talk about that idea as well? It's not only possible, it actually is the case that when people are asked the same question or evaluate the same thing on multiple occasions, they do not reach the same answers. For example, radiologists who have shown the same image on two separate occasions and are not reminded that it's the same image, really with distressing frequency reach different diagnoses on the two occasions.
但也可能是，如果你在早上审查一个案件，而你在下午审查一个案件，可能仅仅在你自己的内心，你自己的判断也可能是嘈杂的。你也能谈谈那个想法吗？这不仅是可能的，实际上确实是这样，当人们在多个场合被问到同一个问题或评估同一件事时，他们不会得出相同的答案。例如，放射科医生在两个不同的场合被展示同一张图像，并且没有被提醒这是同一张图像，确实以令人不安的频率在两个场合得出不同的诊断。
That we know. It's true even for fingerprint examiners, whom we really would not expect to be noisy at all, but actually they vary when you show them the same fingerprints twice. By the way, that's important. They do not vary in the sense that somebody would make a match on one occasion and would positively say it is not a match on the other. But fingerprint examiners are allowed to say, I'm not sure.
我们知道这一点。即使对于指纹鉴定员来说也是如此，我们真的不希望他们有任何噪音，但实际上当你两次向他们展示相同的指纹时，他们会发生变化。顺便说一句，这很重要。他们并不是在某种意义上发生变化，即某人在一个场合会做出匹配，而在另一个场合会肯定地说这不是匹配。但指纹鉴定员被允许说，我不确定。
And between I'm not sure and I am sure that it's a match or it's not a match, there is variability. One of the things that you point out is that you don't expect that the lottery of who is reviewing your file is going to make a huge difference or that extraneous factors would play a huge role. The researcher Uri Simonson found that college admissions officers pay more attention to the academic attributes of candidates on cloudy days and to non-academic attributes when the weather is sunny. He titled his paper, Clouds Make Nerds Look Good. Talk about this idea that
而在“我不确定”和“我确定它是匹配或它不是匹配”之间，存在变异性。你指出的事情之一是，你不会期望谁在审查你的档案的彩票会产生巨大的差异，或者无关因素会发挥巨大的作用。研究人员Uri Simonson发现，大学招生官在阴天更关注候选人的学术属性，而在天气晴朗时更关注非学术属性。他给他的论文命名为《云彩让书呆子看起来不错》。谈谈这个想法，即
extraneous factors, whether someone's hungry, what the weather is like, that can affect people's judgment too. Indeed, it's been established in the justice system. If you're a defendant, you have to hope for good weather because on very hot days, judges assign more severe sentences. And that is true, although judges are air-conditioned, but it's the outside temperature nevertheless seems to have an effect. It's been established in at least one study that for judges who are keen on football the result of their team on Sunday or Saturday depending on whether it's professional or
无关因素，无论是某人饿了，天气如何，也会影响人们的判断。确实，这在司法系统中已经得到证实。如果你是被告，你必须祈祷天气好，因为在非常炎热的日子里，法官会判处更严厉的刑罚。这是真的，尽管法官有空调，但室外温度似乎仍然有影响。至少有一项研究证实，对于热衷于足球的法官来说，他们球队在周日或周六的结果（取决于它是职业还是
college will affect the judgment they make on the Monday and they will be more severe if their team lost. No! He missed the extra point wide right! That's a terrifying idea isn't it Danny, that you're sort of hoping that your judges football team wins the Sunday before your case is heard. Yes, absolutely and you are also hoping to find a judge who is in a good mood, to find a judge who has rested, has had a good night, who is not too tired. And your chances of being prescribed antibiotics or painkillers differ in the course of the day.
大学）会影响他们在周一做出的判断，如果他们的球队输了，他们会更严厉。不！他错过了加分，偏右了！那是一个可怕的想法，不是吗，丹尼，你有点希望你的法官的足球队在你案件审理前的周日获胜。是的，绝对，而且你也希望找到一个心情好的法官，找到一个休息好了、睡了个好觉、不太累的法官。而你被开抗生素或止痛药的机会在一天中会有所不同。
So doctors tend to prescribe more antibiotics toward the end of the day when they are tired than earlier in the day when they are fresh. And they are more likely to prescribe painkillers later in the day simply because it's an effort to resist the patient who wants painkillers. And when you're very tired and depleted, that effort becomes more difficult. So completely extraneous factors have a distressingly large effect. Noise in medicine often shows up under a different name. Medical mistakes.
所以医生倾向于在一天结束时他们累了的时候比在一天开始时他们精神饱满的时候开更多的抗生素。而且他们更有可能在一天晚些时候开止痛药，仅仅是因为这是一种抵制想要止痛药的病人的努力。而当你非常疲惫和耗尽时，这种努力变得更加困难。所以完全无关的因素有令人不安的巨大影响。医学中的噪音通常以不同的名字出现。医疗错误。
Stunning medical news tonight about how many Americans have something go wrong when they go to the hospital. The astronomical number, one in three patients, will face a mistake during a hospital stay. And these are costly errors. One study estimating medical mistakes cost the US more than $17 billion a year. The doctors had discovered that Sarah didn't have cancer in the first place. She'd been misdiagnosed, and all the pain and treatment that she went through was for absolutely nothing. So Danny, can you talk about these two different dimensions of noise in the medical sphere,
今晚关于有多少美国人在去医院时出错的惊人医疗新闻。这个天文数字，三分之一的病人，在住院期间会面临一个错误。这些是代价高昂的错误。一项研究估计医疗错误每年给美国造成超过170亿美元的损失。医生们发现莎拉根本没有癌症。她被误诊了，她所经历的所有痛苦和治疗都是完全徒劳的。所以丹尼，你能谈谈医疗领域中噪音的这两个不同维度吗，
the ways in which it might cause us to get diagnosed with conditions we might not have, but also for doctors to miss conditions and problems that we actually do have? but also for doctors to miss conditions and problems that we actually do have. The contribution of noise is that which physician looks at the data makes a difference. And there is a lot of that. That is, we know that physicians disagree on diagnosis and they also disagree on treatment. And that is a little shocking that there is that element of lottery. So errors could happen for many reasons, including luck, which is not an error in judgment, but where information was missing.
它们可能导致我们被诊断出我们可能没有的疾病，但也可能导致医生错过我们确实有的疾病和问题？但也会导致医生错过我们确实有的疾病和问题。噪音的贡献在于，哪位医生看数据会有所不同。而且有很多这种情况。也就是说，我们知道医生在诊断上存在分歧，他们在治疗上也存在分歧。这有点令人震惊，存在那种彩票因素。所以错误可能由于许多原因发生，包括运气，这不是判断上的错误，而是信息缺失的地方。
But in some cases, the errors cannot be described in any other way than noise, that is, different doctors looking at the same case, reaching different conclusions. It might seem obvious from these examples that noise is a big problem and that combating noise makes a lot of sense. Who could argue against reducing arbitrary decisions and inconsistent rules?
但在某些情况下，错误无法用除了噪音之外的任何方式来描述，也就是说，不同的医生看同一个病例，得出不同的结论。从这些例子中，噪音是一个大问题，对抗噪音很有意义，这似乎是显而易见的。谁会反对减少武断的决定和不一致的规则呢？
It turns out a lot of people have a problem with doing just that, and one of those people might be you. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've seen how noise pervades many aspects of our personal and social lives. It can lead to wildly different estimates on our insurance premiums. It affects judgments doctors make about our health.
事实证明，很多人对这样做有问题，而这些人中可能包括你。你正在收听Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们已经看到了噪音如何渗透到我们个人和社会生活的许多方面。它可能导致我们保费的估计大相径庭。它影响医生对我们健康的判断。
It can determine whether we get a job or a promotion. In their new book, Noise, a flaw in human judgment, Daniel Kahneman and his co-authors, Olivier Sibony and Cass Sunstein, show that noise also shapes what happens in the criminal justice system. It affects decisions that send people to prison or sentence them to execution. Danny Judge Marvin Frankel worked as a United States district judge and he made a name for himself by pointing out inconsistencies in the criminal justice system. He once wrote a case about two men convicted for cashing counterfeit checks. Both amounts were for less than 60
它决定了我们是否能得到工作或晋升。在他们的新书《噪音：人类判断的缺陷》中，丹尼尔·卡尼曼和他的合著者奥利维尔·西博尼和卡斯·桑斯坦表明，噪音也塑造了刑事司法系统中发生的事情。它影响将人们送进监狱或判处死刑的决定。丹尼，马文·弗兰克尔法官曾担任美国地区法官，他通过指出刑事司法系统中的不一致之处而闻名。他曾经写过一个关于两名因兑现伪造支票而被定罪的男子的案件。两个金额都不到60
dollars. One man got a sentence of 30 days in prison. The other got 15 years. What did Judge Frankel make of such disparities? I mean, he thought it's unjust. He thought it's extraordinarily unfair, which it seems to be on the face of it. So he really felt that the justice system should be reformed to avoid this role of completely unpredictable, unreasonable factors that determine the fate of defendants. You know, Danny, I feel like in the last year, I've seen dozens of stories that talk about disparities of all kinds, including disparities in the criminal justice system.
美元。一个人被判处30天监禁。另一个人被判了15年。弗兰克尔法官对这种差异有什么看法？我的意思是，他认为这是不公正的。他认为这极其不公平，从表面上看确实如此。所以他真的觉得司法系统应该改革，以避免这种决定被告命运的完全不可预测、不合理的因素的作用。你知道，丹尼，我觉得在过去的一年里，我看到了几十个谈论各种差异的故事，包括刑事司法系统中的差异。
And invariably when I read these stories about disparities, they talk about the idea that it's about bias, that it's about racial bias or gender bias or some other kind of bias. So when Judge Frankel comes along and says, you know, defendants are being given vastly different sentences, the very first thing that pops in my head is maybe these defendants were of different races and what we're really seeing is racial bias at play rather than noise. How can we tell the difference between racial bias and noise? It's actually easy to do because when you want to measure noise, you can conduct a kind
而且当我读到这些关于差异的故事时，他们总是谈论这是关于偏见，是关于种族偏见或性别偏见或其他某种偏见。所以当弗兰克尔法官出现并说，你知道，被告被判处了截然不同的刑罚，我脑子里冒出的第一件事是，也许这些被告属于不同的种族，我们真正看到的是种族偏见在起作用，而不是噪音。我们如何区分种族偏见和噪音？这实际上很容易做到，因为当你想要衡量噪音时，你可以进行一种
of study that we call the noise audit. And so you take professionals, for example, judges, and you show them a fictitious case. And you ask them to make judgments as they would normally. Now you know that it's the same case, they've all been given the same information. They should give you the same judgment. The differences among them cannot be attributed to bias. And indeed, what Judge Frenkel caused to happen, he caused many noise audits to be performed. He actually conducted some himself. And in the most famous one, 208 federal judges
我们称之为“噪音审计”的研究。所以你找专业人士，例如法官，向他们展示一个虚构的案件。你要求他们像往常一样做出判断。现在你知道这是同一个案件，他们都得到了相同的信息。他们应该给你相同的判断。他们之间的差异不能归因于偏见。事实上，弗兰克尔法官促成了很多噪音审计的执行。他实际上自己也进行了一些。在最著名的一次中，208名联邦法官
eight federal judges evaluated 16 cases and assigned sentences to 16 cases. And this gives you an idea of the lottery that the defendant would face in that where the average sentence is seven years in jail, the probable difference between two judgments is over three years. So that seems to be unacceptable. So based on the work of Judge Frankel and others, Congress eventually passed a law that basically limited the amount of discretion that judges had. Talk about the effects that this law had on reducing noise.
八名联邦法官评估了16个案件，并为16个案件分配了刑罚。这让你了解了被告将面临的彩票，其中平均刑罚是7年监禁，两个判断之间的可能差异超过3年。所以这似乎是不可接受的。因此，基于弗兰克尔法官和其他人的工作，国会最终通过了一项法律，基本上限制了法官拥有的自由裁量权。谈谈这项法律在减少噪音方面的效果。
Were there studies conducted to actually figure out if these were reducing noise? Yes, studies were conducted and actually you can look at many cases and look at the variability of judgments in many cases and you find that the variability significantly diminished, which indicates that their noise was in fact reduced. However, something else happened. The judges hated it. They hated this restriction on their ability to make free decisions, and they felt that
是否有进行研究来真正弄清楚这些是否在减少噪音？是的，进行了研究，实际上你可以查看许多案件并查看许多案件中判断的变异性，你会发现变异性显著减少，这表明他们的噪音实际上减少了。然而，发生了另一件事。法官们讨厌它。他们讨厌这种对他们做出自由决定能力的限制，他们觉得
justice was not being served. So, even as the data was showing that the noise was reducing in sentencing, in other words, sentencing was becoming more consistent, many judges were upset that their discretion was being taken away. And Judge Jose Cabranes was one of those who spoke up. And I want to play you a clip of something he said in 1994. This was a discussion at Harvard University where they were talking about these guidelines that were aimed to reduce ethnic disparities in sentencing by limiting the amount of discretion
正义没有得到伸张。所以，即使数据表明量刑中的噪音正在减少，换句话说，量刑变得更加一致，许多法官仍然对他们的自由裁量权被剥夺感到不满。何塞·卡布拉内斯法官就是其中之一。我想播放一段他在1994年说的话的片段。这是哈佛大学的一次讨论，他们正在谈论这些旨在通过限制法官拥有的自由裁量权来减少量刑中种族差异的指导方针
that judges had. Here is Judge Cabranes. These arcane and mechanistic computations are intended to produce a form of scientific precision, but in practice, they generate a dense fog of confusion that undermines the legitimacy of the judge's sentencing decisions. Dhani, I want to draw your attention to what Judge Cabranes is saying. When you limit the variability of sentencing, you're telling judges, for this offense, you have to do X, for that offense, you have to do Y. A lot of judges feel their hands are tied and they feel the art of law is being reduced to a mechanistic science.
。这是卡布拉内斯法官。这些深奥和机械的计算旨在产生一种科学的精确性，但在实践中，它们产生了一层浓厚的混乱迷雾，破坏了法官量刑决定的合法性。丹尼，我想请你注意卡布拉内斯法官在说什么。当你限制量刑的变异性时，你是在告诉法官，对于这个罪行，你必须做X，对于那个罪行，你必须做Y。很多法官觉得他们的手被束缚了，他们觉得法律的艺术正在被简化为一种机械的科学。
Well, if it takes a mechanistic science to produce justice, then I think we should seriously consider some mechanistic science. What seems to be happening is that from the perspective of the judge, they feel that they're evaluating every detail of the case and that they are producing a just judgment because they are convinced that what they are doing is a just judgment. And somehow it's very difficult to convince judges that another judge whom they respect a great deal presented with the same case would actually pass a different sentence. That argument doesn't seem to have penetrated when Judge Cabrón has made that assertion
好吧，如果需要一种机械化的科学才能实现正义，那么我认为我们应该认真考虑一下机械化的科学。目前的情况似乎是，从法官的角度来看，他们觉得自己在评估案件的每一个细节，并且因为确信自己所做的是公正的判决，所以他们认为自己正在做出公正的判决。不知何故，要让法官相信他们非常尊重的另一位法官在面对同样的案件时会做出不同的判决，是非常困难的。当卡布隆法官做出这种断言时，这种论点似乎并没有产生影响。
that in fact there is a problem and there is a problem to be resolved. He was in effect, as I hear him, he was denying the existence of a problem. Psychologists talk about a phenomenon called naive realism that in some ways explains why it is, I am bewildered that you would not see the world exactly the way that I see the world. Can you explain what naive realism is and how it speaks to the question we just discussed about judges not just reaching different conclusions but being bewildered
事实上，这里存在一个问题，而且是一个需要解决的问题。据我所听到的，他实际上是在否认问题的存在。心理学家谈到了一种叫做“朴素实在论”的现象，它在某种程度上解释了为什么我会对你不能完全按照我的方式看待世界感到困惑。你能解释一下什么是朴素实在论，以及它如何回应我们刚才讨论的关于法官不仅得出不同结论，而且感到困惑的问题吗？
that anyone would reach a different conclusion than them? Well, you know, we feel that we see the world as it is. It's the only way we see it, and what we see is real, what we see is true. And it makes it very difficult to believe and to imagine that someone else looking at the same reality is going to see it differently. But in fact, we are struck by how different they are in the context of criminal justice. The variability in sentences is shocking. But when you're looking at it from the perspective of a judge who looks at cases individually and feels that he or she is making correct judgments
即任何人都会得出与他们不同的结论？嗯，你知道，我们觉得我们看到的世界就是它本来的样子。这是我们看待它的唯一方式，我们所看到的是真实的，我们所看到的是正确的。这使得我们很难相信和想象，别人在观察同样的现实时会以不同的方式看待它。但事实上，我们对他们在刑事司法背景下的差异之大感到震惊。量刑的差异令人震惊。但是，当你从一个法官的角度来看待它时，他或她会单独审视案件，并觉得他或她正在做出正确的判断。
for every case individually, then it looks as if any attempt to restrict their freedom is going to cause injustice to be performed. But they're simply not accepting, I think, the statistics that tell them that another judge looking at the same case would actually pass a different sentence. So these debates about sentencing reform raged in the 1980s and 1990s, and eventually in the early 2000s, the Supreme Court struck down the guidelines that bound the way judges were operating, and sentencing reform essentially went away, giving discretion back to judges. Is what happened what I fear happened? Did noise come back into the system? Oh, yes
对于每一个单独的案件，那么看起来任何限制他们自由的尝试都会导致不公正的发生。但我认为，他们只是不接受那些告诉他们另一位法官在审视同一案件时会做出不同判决的统计数据。因此，关于量刑改革的辩论在20世纪80年代和90年代非常激烈，最终在21世纪初，最高法院推翻了约束法官运作方式的指导方针，量刑改革基本上消失了，将自由裁量权还给了法官。发生的事情是我所担心的吗？噪音又回到了系统中吗？哦，是的。
I mean there is evidence that noise came roaring back and there is also evidence that judges were a lot happier Without the guidelines than they had been earlier One of the ironic things that you and others have found is that even though there is this distinction between noise and bias When the noise came back after the Supreme Court ruling have found is that even though there is this distinction between noise and bias, when the noise came back after the Supreme Court ruling, black defendants were actually among those who were the most severely harmed by this. Is it possible in some ways they can be intersections between noise and bias? In other words, they can amplify one another?
我的意思是，有证据表明噪音卷土重来，也有证据表明法官在没有指导方针的情况下比以前快乐得多。你和其他人发现的一个讽刺之处在于，尽管噪音和偏见之间存在这种区别，但当最高法院裁决后噪音回来时，黑人被告实际上是受此影响最严重的人群之一。在某种程度上，噪音和偏见之间是否存在交叉点？换句话说，它们可以相互放大吗？
Certainly. I mean, when you are constraining people and reducing noise, you're reducing the opportunities for bias to take place. So attempts to reduce noise and attempts to control noise are going to, in general, not invariably, but are very likely to control and reduce bias as well. If noise produces many of the adverse outcomes we see, if noise produces much of the unfairness we see, why is it that critiques of disparities invariably talk about bias? Turns out that's because of the way our minds work.
当然。我的意思是，当你约束人们并减少噪音时，你就减少了偏见发生的机会。因此，减少噪音和控制噪音的尝试通常（并非总是）很可能也会控制和减少偏见。如果噪音产生了我们看到的许多不利结果，如果噪音产生了我们看到的许多不公平现象，为什么对差异的批评总是谈论偏见？事实证明，这是因为我们大脑的工作方式。
The brain is a storytelling machine and the story of bias caters to our hunger for simple explanations. I mean, clearly, bias in general is a better story. That is, you see something happening, it had the character of an event, it had the character of something that is caused by a psychological force of some kind. Variability, noise, is uncaused. Noise doesn't lend itself to a causal story. And really the mind is hungry for causes. And that leads us very naturally to think in terms of biases.
大脑是一台讲故事的机器，偏见的故事迎合了我们对简单解释的渴望。我的意思是，显然，偏见通常是一个更好的故事。也就是说，你看到某事发生，它具有事件的特征，它具有某种心理力量引起的特征。变异性，即噪音，是无缘无故的。噪音本身并不适合讲因果故事。而大脑确实渴望原因。这自然而然地引导我们从偏见的角度去思考。
That errors must be explainable. So if I get a misdiagnosis because a doctor doesn't like the color of my skin, that might not make me feel good, but at least I can make sense of what happened. Once I settle on an explanation of racism or sexism or homophobia, I tell myself I have every right to get angry. When I discuss what happened with others, they'll get angry too. By contrast, a misdiagnosis produced by noise is, by definition, no one's fault. The error may have harmed me, but I can't lay the blame on someone's evil intentions.
即错误必须是可以解释的。所以，如果我因为医生不喜欢我的肤色而得到误诊，这可能不会让我感觉良好，但至少我可以理解发生了什么。一旦我确定了种族主义、性别歧视或恐同症的解释，我就告诉自己我有充分的理由生气。当我与他人讨论发生的事情时，他们也会生气。相比之下，由噪音产生的误诊，根据定义，不是任何人的错。错误可能伤害了我，但我不能把责任归咎于某人的邪恶动机。
Noise is the very opposite of a good story. It's meaningless, and that can make me feel even worse. Here's another problem. When I see a judge pass a really harsh sentence or a very light sentence, I can come up with a story of bias to explain this individual case. You cannot do that with noise. You cannot spot noise by looking at any individual case. You have to measure it in the aggregate. It shows up only when you look at the statistics, and many of us are uncomfortable turning to data as our guide to the truth. We prefer stories and anecdotes, and stories and anecdotes are better at illustrating the problem of bias. Stories and anecdotes are what the mind is prepared for. Statistical thinking is alien to us.
噪音与好故事恰恰相反。它是毫无意义的，这甚至会让我感觉更糟。这是另一个问题。当我看到法官做出非常严厉或非常轻的判决时，我可以编造一个偏见的故事来解释这个个案。你不能用噪音做到这一点。你不能通过观察任何个案来发现噪音。你必须在总体上衡量它。它只有在你查看统计数据时才会显现出来，而我们许多人对转向数据作为真理指南感到不舒服。我们更喜欢故事和轶事，而故事和轶事在说明偏见问题方面更好。故事和轶事是大脑准备好接受的东西。统计思维对我们来说是陌生的。
And statistical thinking is the only way to detect noise, because it's variability. It's sort of absurd to say about any single case that it is noisy. You say that if you have no idea of how it came about. But noise is a phenomenon that you observe statistically and that you can analyze only statistically. And that is not appealing. So there's an even deeper problem than the fact that noise is detectable only through statistics whereas bias, you know, you can tell a story about bias. So there's an even deeper problem than the fact that noise is detectable only through statistics
而统计思维是检测噪音的唯一方法，因为它是一种变异性。说任何单一案件是“嘈杂的”有点荒谬。如果你不知道它是如何产生的，你就会这么说。但噪音是一种你从统计学上观察到的现象，而且你只能从统计学上进行分析。这并不吸引人。所以，这里有一个比“噪音只能通过统计数据检测到，而偏见可以讲故事”更深层的问题。所以，这里有一个比“噪音只能通过统计数据检测到”更深层的问题。
Whereas bias, you know, you can tell a story about bias for many people making decisions. The data is simply not even available So at a statistical level you can see an insurance company is demonstrating noise But many of the decisions we are making our decisions we make as individuals So if I want to propose marriage and I feel like proposing marriage on a moonlit night in the springtime, I have no idea if my decision to propose marriage on that evening is being shaped by noise or not. I don't have a statistical set of how I would behave under different circumstances. You know, the truth of the matter is that no one can tell you that this decision was noisy. What you can tell is that when you look at the collection of decisions of people deciding
而偏见，你知道，你可以为许多做决定的人讲一个关于偏见的故事。数据根本不可用。所以在统计层面上，你可以看到一家保险公司表现出噪音，但我们做出的许多决定是我们作为个人做出的决定。所以，如果我想求婚，我觉得想在春天的月光之夜求婚，我不知道我那天晚上求婚的决定是否受到噪音的影响。我没有关于我在不同情况下会如何表现的统计集。你知道，事实是，没有人能告诉你这个决定是嘈杂的。你可以说的是，当你观察人们决定求婚的决定集合时。
to get married, that collection is noisy. There is no reason to believe that these steps which improve judgments in the statistical case do not apply when somebody decides to get married. If noise is present in the decisions where you can observe it, it's also present when you cannot observe it. Hmm. Some years ago I interviewed the researcher Berkeley Dietworst. He talked about how people respond when a mistake has been made by a human versus an algorithm. I want to play you a short excerpt of something he told me. People failed to use the algorithm after they'd seen the algorithm perform and
结婚，那个集合是嘈杂的。没有理由相信这些在统计案例中改善判断的步骤在某人决定结婚时不适用。如果噪音存在于你可以观察到的决定中，那么它也存在于你无法观察到的决定中。嗯。几年前，我采访了研究员伯克利·迪特沃斯特。他谈到了当人类与算法犯错时人们如何反应。我想给你播放一小段他告诉我的片段。人们在看到算法表现并犯错后，即使他们通常看到算法的表现优于人类，也没有使用该算法。
make mistakes even though they typically saw the algorithm outperform the human. In our studies the algorithms outperform people by 25 to 90 percent. So he's basically saying the algorithms are significantly better than the humans but when a mistake is made and algorithms of course can make mistakes and humans can make mistakes, he's saying that you prefer the human to make the mistake. And I think intuitively that feels correct to me. If I'm going to get a misdiagnosis when I go to a doctor, I would feel better if it's the doctor who's made the mistake than an unfeeling, unthinking algorithm.
在我们的研究中，算法的表现比人类好25%到90%。所以他基本上是在说算法明显优于人类，但当犯错时（当然算法会犯错，人类也会犯错），他说你更喜欢人类犯错。我认为直觉上这对我来说是正确的。如果我去看医生时得到误诊，如果犯错的是医生而不是一个没有感情、不会思考的算法，我会感觉更好。
I think that's absolutely true. And when we're looking at a road accident, we somehow feel less bad about it if it was a driver error than if it was a self-driving car that caused the accident. Algorithms, they make errors. The error they make, by the way, are different from the errors that people would make, and they look stupid to people. Algorithm make errors that people think are ridiculous.
我认为这绝对是真的。当我们看到道路交通事故时，如果这是驾驶员错误，我们不知何故会比自动驾驶汽车导致事故感觉更糟。算法，它们会犯错。顺便说一句，它们犯的错误与人们会犯的错误不同，而且在人们看来它们看起来很愚蠢。算法犯的错误，人们认为是很荒谬的。
Now we don't get to hear what algorithm think of the errors that people make. And we do know that algorithm just make far fewer of them in many cases. And you have to trade off the higher overall accuracy against the discomfort of abandoning human judgment and trusting an algorithm. Yeah. You know, this might actually be a subtext of much of your lifetime's work, Danny, but it seems to me that fighting noise requires a certain amount of humility. And it seems to me that humans are not humble. Well, they're not humble for a fairly straightforward reason. We do not go through life imagining different ways of seeing what
现在我们听不到算法对人们犯的错误有什么看法。我们确实知道，在许多情况下，算法犯的错误要少得多。你必须权衡更高的整体准确性与放弃人类判断和信任算法的不适感。是的。你知道，这实际上可能是你一生工作的大部分潜台词，丹尼，但在我看来，对抗噪音需要一定程度的谦逊。在我看来，人类并不谦逊。好吧，他们不谦逊的原因很简单。我们不会在生活中想象不同的看待事物的方式。
we see. We see one thing at a time, and it feels right to us. And, you know, that is really the source of the problem of ignoring noise. This is why it is so difficult to imagine it. I want to talk just for a brief moment about places where noise can potentially be useful. So let's say, for example, you have a company that's trying to innovate and come up with new ideas, or you're in a creative enterprise where you want to pitch different ideas for movies. In some ways, you might want to actually maximize the variability of the ideas you get.
我们一次只看一件事，这让我们感觉是对的。而且，你知道，这确实是忽视噪音问题的根源。这就是为什么很难想象它。我想简短地谈谈噪音可能有用处的地方。所以，假设你有一家公司试图创新并提出新想法，或者你处于一个创意企业，你想为电影推销不同的想法。在某些方面，你可能实际上想要最大化你获得的想法的变异性。
So, noise is not always bad. Sometimes it can actually lead to good things. Yeah. We don't call it noise in those cases. We reserve the term noise for undesirable variability. There are indeed many situations in life in which variability is a blessing, certainly in creative enterprises, also evolution. So anything that allows you to select the better one of multiple responses, wherever there is a selection mechanism, Variability is a good thing, but
所以，噪音并不总是坏事。有时它实际上可以导致好的结果。是的。在这些情况下，我们不称之为噪音。我们将“噪音”一词保留给不可取的变异性。生活中确实有许多情况变异性是一种福气，当然在创意企业中是这样，进化也是如此。所以任何允许你从多个反应中选择较好的一个的东西，只要有选择机制的地方，变异性就是一件好事，但是
variability in the absence of a selection mechanism is a sheer loss of accuracy. And those are the cases that we talk about. So if you had a way when you have multiple underwriters of finding out who is doing a better job than whom. And using that in order to improve their training, that would be a case where you could make positive use of variability. But in the absence of such a mechanism, that variability just is a sheer loss.
在没有选择机制的情况下，变异性纯粹是准确性的损失。而这些就是我们谈论的案例。所以，如果你有一种方法，当你有多个承保人时，找出谁做得比谁好。并利用这一点来改善他们的培训，那将是一个你可以积极利用变异性的案例。但在缺乏这种机制的情况下，这种变异性纯粹是一种损失。
When we come back, how to fight noise? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Noise is endemic. It's also very difficult to fight, in part because judges and doctors and police officers don't like to think of themselves as capricious.
回来后，如何对抗噪音？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。噪音是地方性的。它也非常难以对抗，部分原因是法官、医生和警察不喜欢认为自己是反复无常的。
We don't think of our judgments as being arbitrary, certainly not when it comes to really important decisions. Even when we are told about how noise is affecting our judgments and decisions, we hate to be shackled by rules. Danny, in 1907, Charles Darwin's cousin, Francis Galton, asked 787 villagers at a county fair to estimate the weight of a prize ox. None of the villagers guessed the right answer, but then Galton did something with their answers that got him very close to the correct answer. What did he do, Danny? Well, he simply took the average
我们不认为我们的判断是武断的，当然在涉及非常重要的决定时更是如此。即使当我们被告知噪音如何影响我们的判断和决定时，我们也讨厌被规则束缚。丹尼，1907年，查尔斯·达尔文的表弟弗朗西斯·高尔顿要求乡村集市上的787名村民估计一头获奖公牛的重量。没有一个村民猜对了答案，但后来高尔顿用他们的答案做了一些事情，使他非常接近正确答案。他做了什么，丹尼？好吧，他只是取了平均值。
and the average, I think, was within two pounds of the correct weight. And that led to a lot of research that was summarized in a recent book by James Surowiecki on the wisdom of crowds and the fact that when you take multiple judgments, independent judgments, and average them, you eliminate noise. This by the way is guaranteed to eliminate noise. So if you take multiple judgments there is no guarantee that it will reduce bias because if the judges agree on the bias
而平均值，我想，在正确重量的两磅之内。这导致了詹姆斯·索罗维基最近的一本书中总结的大量关于群体智慧的研究，以及当你采取多个判断、独立判断并取平均值时，你消除了噪音的事实。顺便说一句，这保证能消除噪音。所以，如果你采取多个判断，不能保证它会减少偏见，因为如果法官在偏见上达成一致。
then the bias will remain when you take the average. Indeed it will be even more salient. But what is absolutely guaranteed is that when you average independent judgments you are eliminating noise. When you take four independent judges, you're reducing noise by one half. When you take 100, you're reducing it by 90%. So there is some mathematics of noise that lends itself to analysis that doesn't apply to bias. So it's really remarkable. The correct weight of that ox was 1,198 pounds and
那么当你取平均值时，偏见仍然存在。事实上，它会更加突出。但绝对保证的是，当你对独立判断取平均值时，你正在消除噪音。当你采取四个独立法官时，你将噪音减少了一半。当你采取100个时，你减少了90%。所以有一些噪音的数学原理适合分析，而不适用于偏见。所以这真的很了不起。那头公牛的正确重量是1198磅，而
as you said that was one or two pounds off the correct weight. And I want to point out that the reason averaging the responses produces a better answer is that noise is random. You're taking advantage of the fact that various estimates will be randomly high or low and that's why when you average them out you're going to get closer and closer to the correct answer. What happens when you have different people making the same judgment of the same object, and then you are going to average them, then the errors they make cancel each other out. But when people make judgments about different cases, errors don't cancel them out.
正如你所说，那与正确重量相差一两磅。我想指出的是，对反应取平均值产生更好答案的原因是噪音是随机的。你利用了各种估计会随机偏高或偏低的事实，这就是为什么当你对它们取平均值时，你会越来越接近正确答案。当你让不同的人对同一个对象做出相同的判断，然后你要对它们取平均值时，他们犯的错误会相互抵消。但当人们对不同的案件做出判断时，错误不会抵消它们。
If you set too high a premium in one case and too low a premium in the other case, that doesn't make you right. That just makes things worse. So this idea that errors cancel out, you have to apply it quite precisely. They cancel out when your average judgments are the same thing.
如果你在一个案件中设置了过高的保费，而在另一个案件中设置了过低的保费，那并不能证明你是对的。那只会让事情变得更糟。所以这个错误会抵消的想法，你必须非常精确地应用它。当你的平均判断是同一件事时，它们会抵消。
And also the judgments have to come from people who in some ways who are independent of one another. If I'm seeing the judgment you make and then I make my judgment afterwards, my judgment really is just a reflection of your judgment, not an independent one. That's right. And you know what happens basically is when you have witnesses who talk to each other, the value of their testimony is sharply reduced. Because in effect, in the extreme, if you have one witness who is very assertive, all the other witnesses fit their story to his, then you have one witness, regardless of how many testify.
而且判断也必须来自在某种程度上彼此独立的人。如果我看到了你做出的判断，然后我随后做出我的判断，我的判断实际上只是你判断的反映，而不是独立的。没错。你知道基本上发生的事情是，当你有互相交谈的证人时，他们证词的价值会急剧下降。因为实际上，在极端情况下，如果你有一个非常自信的证人，所有其他证人都根据他的话调整他们的故事，那么你只有一个证人，无论有多少人作证。
One of the most remarkable aspects of the wisdom of the crowd that you describe in the book has to do with How you can elicit the wisdom of the crowd just from yourself you cite research by Edward Vool and Harold Paschler that ask people to make judgments about the same thing Separated by a certain amount of time. What do they find when you average out these different estimates? well, for example, you know if if you ask people, what did the population of London? And you ask it once, and then you wait a couple of weeks, say, and you ask it again. The striking thing is that most people will not give you the same number on the two occasions. And the second striking thing is that the average of the two responses is more likely
你在书中描述的群体智慧最显著的方面之一与你如何仅从自己身上引出群体智慧有关。你引用了爱德华·沃尔和哈罗德·帕什勒的研究，要求人们在相隔一定时间的情况下对同一件事做出判断。当你们对这些不同的估计取平均值时，他们发现了什么？嗯，例如，你知道，如果你问人们，伦敦的人口是多少？你问一次，然后你等几个星期，比如说，你再问一次。令人震惊的是，大多数人在两次场合不会给你相同的数字。第二个令人震惊的事情是，两个反应的平均值更有可能
to be accurate than either of the responses. The first response is better than the second, but the average is better than both. In one of the studies they conducted, they actually asked people to make estimates that were different than their initial estimates, and then they averaged out the estimates and they found that noise was reduced even further. Why would this be the case, Danny? Well, here what you're trying to do, and you can do it within an individual, is you're leaning against yourself.
准确，而不是任何一个反应。第一个反应比第二个好，但平均值比两者都好。在他们进行的一项研究中，他们实际上要求人们做出与他们最初估计不同的估计，然后他们对估计取平均值，发现噪音进一步减少了。为什么会这样，丹尼？好吧，在这里你试图做的是，你可以在个人内部做到这一点，你是在依靠自己。
You made one judgment and then you ask people to think, how could that judgment be wrong, and then make another? And that turns out to be, indeed, better than merely asking the same question twice. In some ways, this provides a solution to the conundrum I pose to Danny. If noise is detectable only by studying statistical averages, how do I reduce noise in decisions I am making as an individual? The answer?
你做了一个判断，然后你要求人们思考，那个判断怎么可能是错的，然后再做一个？事实证明，这确实比仅仅问同一个问题两次要好。在某种程度上，这为我向丹尼提出的难题提供了一个解决方案。如果噪音只能通过研究统计平均值来检测，我如何减少我作为个人所做决定中的噪音？答案是什么？
Try to make the same decision over and over under different conditions. One way to tell if noise is behind my decision to propose marriage is to ask myself whether I would make the same decision under different circumstances, not just on a moonlit night in the springtime, but in the heat of summer or in the dead of winter. If I reach the same answer in these different settings, it's possible I could still be making a mistake, but at least I can be somewhat reassured that my decision is not the result of random, extraneous factors. Scientists are exploring lots of ways to reduce noise.
尝试在不同条件下反复做出相同的决定。判断我求婚的决定背后是否有噪音的一种方法是问自己，我是否会在不同情况下做出相同的决定，不仅是在春天的月光之夜，而且是在炎热的夏天或严冬。如果我在这些不同设置中得出相同的答案，我可能仍然在犯错，但至少我可以稍微放心，我的决定不是随机、无关因素的结果。科学家们正在探索许多减少噪音的方法。
The researcher Sendhal Mulayanathan and his colleagues devised an algorithm to advise judges on whether to grant bail to suspects. These are people who have been arrested, but who have not yet been put on trial. Keeping them in jail can cause all kinds of hardship. People can lose jobs or lose custody of their children while they're incarcerated awaiting trial. It's costly for taxpayers to keep people in jail. But letting someone dangerous out of jail can cause harm.
研究员森德尔·穆莱纳坦和他的同事设计了一种算法，建议法官是否给予嫌疑人保释。这些人是被捕但尚未受审的人。让他们待在监狱里会导致各种困难。人们在等待审判时被监禁可能会失去工作或失去孩子的监护权。让人们待在监狱里对纳税人来说代价高昂。但让危险的人出狱可能会造成伤害。
Maybe they go on to commit other crimes. The researchers had the algorithm offer advice to judges about whether to grant bail. They found that if judges incorporated the recommendations, this could reduce the number of people in jail by 42% without increasing the risk of crime. 2% without increasing the risk of crime. The research goes further than that in that allowing the algorithm to inform the judge is actually not the best way of doing it. The research suggests quite strongly that when you have a judge and an algorithm that are looking at the same data, with some exceptions, it's better to have the algorithm
也许他们会继续犯下其他罪行。研究人员让算法向法官提供关于是否给予保释的建议。他们发现，如果法官采纳了建议，这可以将监狱中的人数减少42%，而不会增加犯罪风险。2%，而不会增加犯罪风险。这项研究更进一步，即允许算法通知法官实际上并不是最好的做法。研究强烈建议，当你有一个法官和一个算法查看相同的数据时，除了一些例外，最好让算法
have the last word, and this is very non-intuitive. Yeah. Besides being actually superior in some ways in terms of judgment, one of the things that algorithms do better than people is that they're not noisy. They're actually much more consistent. Can you talk about this, that in some ways, one of the advantages that algorithms have
拥有最终决定权，这是非常反直觉的。是的。除了在判断方面在某些方面确实优越之外，算法比人做得更好的一件事是它们不嘈杂。它们实际上要一致得多。你能谈谈这个吗，在某种程度上，算法拥有的优势之一
is even when their judgments might not be as good as humans, because they have less noise than humans, you're able to get better outcomes? Well, noise is a source of inaccuracy. And algorithms, by their nature, are noise-free. That is, when you present the same problem to two computers running the same software, they're going to give you the same answer, which is not true of different bail judges. So that advantage is in many cases sufficient to make algorithms superior to people. But I don't want to create the impression that our solution to the problem
是即使它们的判断可能不如人类好，因为它们比人类噪音更少，你能够获得更好的结果？好吧，噪音是导致不准确的一个来源。而算法，就其本质而言，是无噪音的。也就是说，当你向运行相同软件的两台计算机提出相同的问题时，它们会给你相同的答案，这对于不同的保释法官来说是不真实的。所以这种优势在许多情况下足以使算法优于人类。但我不想制造一种印象，即我们解决问题的方法
of noise is algorithms, because even if it were the solution, there's just too much opposition to algorithms. So ultimately, we're talking about improving judgments. In some domains, algorithms can be used, and I think where they can be used, they should be used, but this is a long process, a slow process because human judgment is going to make the important decisions for quite a while. Isn't it interesting though, Danny, that when you look at the news and you see the news coverage of algorithms,
噪音是算法，因为即使它是解决方案，对算法的反对也太多了。所以最终，我们谈论的是改善判断。在某些领域，可以使用算法，我认为在可以使用的地方，应该使用它们，但这是一个漫长的过程，一个缓慢的过程，因为人类判断将在相当长一段时间内做出重要的决定。丹尼，你不觉得有趣吗，当你查看新闻并看到对算法的新闻报道时，
I feel like just in the last year, I've seen dozens of articles talking about algorithmic bias, about how algorithms in some ways can make judgments worse. And it is the case that you can have poorly designed algorithms. You can argue that the old sentencing rules that we had, three strikes and you're out, in some ways that is an algorithm, but you could argue the algorithm in some ways was too crude to capture what actually needed to be done. But isn't it striking that there's so little attention that's paid by contrast to the potential
我觉得就在去年，我看到了几十篇关于算法偏见的文章，关于算法在某些方面如何使判断变得更糟。确实，你可能会有设计糟糕的算法。你可以争辩说，我们拥有的旧量刑规则，“三振出局”，在某种程度上那是一个算法，但你可以争辩说，该算法在某些方面太粗糙，无法捕捉到实际需要做的事情。但令人震惊的是，相比之下，人们对潜在的
good that algorithms can do? Because again, we're so focused with the story of intent of saying a bad outcome happened and algorithm caused it, clearly algorithms need to be thrown out the window. I mean, we do not want to accept the errors that blind rules will make. You know, I was talking to someone who designs self-driving cars, and they realize that self-driving cars, it's not enough for them to be a hundred times safer than regular drivers. They effectively have to be almost perfect before they will be admitted. And it's that kind of bias that is completely human and natural. We like the natural over the unnatural.
算法可以做的好事关注得如此之少？因为再次，我们太专注于意图的故事，说发生了坏结果，算法导致了它，显然算法需要被扔出窗外。我的意思是，我们不想接受盲目规则会犯的错误。你知道，我正在和一位设计自动驾驶汽车的人交谈，他们意识到自动驾驶汽车，仅仅比普通司机安全一百倍是不够的。它们实际上必须几乎完美才能被准入。而那种偏见是完全人类和自然的。我们喜欢自然的胜过不自然的。
We prefer human drivers and human doctors to make mistakes rather than self-driving cars and medical algorithms. And that's just a fact of psychology. You talk in the book about something that you call decision hygiene, and others have talked about this idea as well. What is decision hygiene and why the analogy to public health? When you're thinking of dealing with bias is like a specific disease. So you can think of a vaccine or you
我们更喜欢人类司机和人类医生犯错，而不是自动驾驶汽车和医疗算法。这只是心理学的一个事实。你在书中谈到了一些你称之为“决策卫生”的东西，其他人也谈到了这个想法。什么是决策卫生，为什么与公共卫生进行类比？当你考虑处理偏见时，就像一种特定的疾病。所以你可以考虑一种疫苗或者你
can think of medication, which is specific to that disease. But when you're washing your hands, you're doing something entirely different. You have no idea what germs you might be killing. And if you're good at it, you will never know because the germs are dead. And a similar distinction can be drawn between different ways of fighting errors.
可以考虑药物，这是针对该疾病的。但当你洗手时，你正在做完全不同的事情。你不知道你可能正在杀死什么细菌。如果你擅长洗手，你永远不会知道，因为细菌已经死了。在对抗错误的不同方式之间可以画出类似的区别。
There is a difference between procedures that are specifically aimed at particular biases and procedures that are intended generally to improve the quality of the judgment and decisions. And the way that this feeds back on the individual is that if there are procedures that are good for organizations and for repeated decisions, they should be good for individuals and for singular decisions. Mm-hmm. So if I'm a CEO of a corporation or if I'm a policymaker and I'm hearing this conversation about noise, can you give me two or three really specific suggestions on ways that I can reduce noise in my decision-making or in my company's decision-making or in my organization
专门针对特定偏见的程序与旨在普遍提高判断和决策质量的程序之间存在区别。这反馈给个人的方式是，如果有一些程序对组织和重复决策有好处，它们也应该对个人和单一决策有好处。嗯。所以，如果我是一家公司的首席执行官，或者如果我是一名决策者，我正在听关于噪音的对话，你能给我两三个关于我如何减少我的决策或我公司决策或我组织中噪音的非常具体的建议吗
or community? Well, I think the first step would be to ask whether you have a task in the organization that is carried out by interchangeable functionaries like underwriters or or emergency room physicians. They're carrying out the same task, making the same kinds of judgments, and you would like those judgments to be noise-free, to be uniform. So first of all, identify whether you have that case in your organization. If you do, we strongly recommend you measure noise. That is, you actually take those individuals, present them with similar cases, and observe
或社区？好吧，我认为第一步是询问你是否在组织中有一项任务是由可互换的功能人员（如承保人或急诊室医生）执行的。他们正在执行相同的任务，做出相同类型的判断，而你希望这些判断是无噪音的，是统一的。所以首先，确定你的组织中是否有这种情况。如果有，我们强烈建议你测量噪音。也就是说，你实际上带走那些个人，向他们展示类似的案例，并观察
the variability in the judgments. And possibly that may lead you to want to do something about it. But the first step is just to measure noise, because our intuitions about the magnitude of noise are systematically wrong. Danny thinks we should learn from the saga of the rise and fall of sentencing reform. Once you detect noise in an organization, we should learn from the saga of the rise and fall of sentencing reform.
判断中的变异性。这可能会导致你想要对此做些什么。但第一步只是测量噪音，因为我们对噪音幅度的直觉是系统性错误的。丹尼认为我们应该从量刑改革兴衰的传奇中学习。一旦你在组织中检测到噪音，我们就应该从量刑改革兴衰的传奇中学习。
Once you detect noise in an organization, it may be wiser to avoid trying to fix the problem by asking everyone to follow rigid rules. As we've seen, people hate to have their judgment questioned, they hate to have their discretion limited, and they detest anything that smacks of mechanistic rules. The main thing to do if you're attempting to improve the judgment of people in an organization is to convince those people that they want their judgments to be better. If you impose it as a set of rules that all of them will follow, they will resist it, they will feel they are being robotized, and they're likely to sabotage whatever you propose.
一旦你在组织中检测到噪音，避免通过要求每个人遵循僵化规则来解决问题可能更明智。正如我们所见，人们讨厌他们的判断受到质疑，他们讨厌他们的自由裁量权受到限制，他们厌恶任何带有机械规则味道的东西。如果你试图改善组织中人们的判断，最主要的事情是说服那些人，他们希望他们的判断更好。如果你把它作为他们都将遵循的一套规则强加给他们，他们会抵制它，他们会觉得他们正在被机器人化，并且他们很可能会破坏你提出的任何建议。
This is well known in insurance companies that provide the underwriters in many cases with information or even with a technical price, with a suggestion about what premium should be assigned. And underwriters are very likely to completely ignore those and to follow their judgment. And basically, I would think, you know, it's obvious advice. If you have a group of people who are noisy, have that group try to find a solution to the noise. Have them develop procedures that will make them uniform, do not impose procedures on them, but work with them to make them more
这在保险公司中是众所周知的，保险公司在许多情况下为承保人提供信息，甚至提供技术价格，提供关于应该分配什么保费的建议。而承保人很可能会完全忽略这些并遵循他们的判断。基本上，我想，你知道，这是显而易见的建议。如果你有一群嘈杂的人，让那群人尝试找到解决噪音的方法。让他们制定使他们统一的程序，不要强加程序给他们，而是与他们合作使他们更
uniform because actually they will recognize that they would like to be in agreement with each other. But letting them feel that what they are doing is what they want to do rather than what they are being forced to do. That is clearly a very important step if people really want to have organizations that improve their judgment. Daniel Kahneman, Olivier Sibony and Cass Sunstein are the authors of Noise, a flaw in human judgment. Danny, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
统一，因为实际上他们会认识到他们希望彼此达成一致。但让他们觉得他们正在做的是他们想做的事情，而不是他们被迫做的事情。如果人们真的想拥有改善判断的组织，这显然是非常重要的一步。丹尼尔·卡尼曼、奥利维尔·西博尼和卡斯·桑斯坦是《噪音：人类判断的缺陷》的作者。丹尼，感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
It was really my pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. This week we say goodbye to someone whose name you've heard many times in the credits of the show. Bridget McCarthy has been a senior producer with Hidden Brains since 2020 and she brought a tireless work ethic to
这真是我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周我们要告别一位你在节目片尾名单中听到过多次名字的人。布里奇特·麦卡锡自2020年以来一直担任《隐藏的大脑》的高级制片人，她带来了不知疲倦的工作道德
everything she produced. We're truly grateful to Bridget for her many, many contributions to the show. If you enjoyed these conversations with Daniel Kahneman, please consider supporting our work so we can continue to bring you many more interviews like this. To do so, you can become a member of our podcast subscription, just find us on Apple Podcasts and sign up for a 7-day free trial of Hidden Brain Plus. Or go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain.
她制作的一切。我们真心感谢布里奇特为节目做出的许多许多贡献。如果你喜欢这些与丹尼尔·卡尼曼的对话，请考虑支持我们的工作，以便我们能继续为你带来更多这样的采访。要做到这一点，你可以成为我们播客订阅的会员，只需在苹果播客上找到我们并注册7天免费试用《隐藏的大脑Plus》。或者访问apple.co/hiddenbrain。
Subscribers receive access to exclusive episodes that you won't hear anywhere else. Thanks for your support. We truly appreciate it. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
订阅者可以获得你在其他任何地方都听不到的独家剧集。感谢你的支持。我们真心感谢。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。